so netflix has updated their corporate
culture memo with an anti-censorship an
anti-censorship
section i got it got it everybody
thank you thank you and uh they
basically said if you are woke and you
don't like what we are buying you can go
pound sand they didn't say like that
they were like maybe this isn't the
right place for you i love it uh you
know the problem is they're losing
subscribers their stock is tanking
because nobody wants to deal with the
stupidity of politics like let me watch
a movie yo but you also got to
understand when they say they're going
to keep running these movies
and they don't they're not going to
tolerate censorship you know they're
also talking about cuties right it's not
just yeah
but for the most part the employees at
netflix and these leftists were
defending cuties so when they say maybe
you should quit they're not talking
about that they're talking about dave
chappelle so good good it's a it's a
a positive change in the culture war
we got a crazy story with elon musk
i i am going to give you my theory elon
musk knew there was fraud at twitter
and he's playing a game to force them to
be exposed i think twitter manipulated
the numbers we know for a fact twitter's
published false user numbers on more
than one occasion
i think elon musk knew that and i think
by doing this deal it's forcing them to
expose how they're manipulating the
public i don't know if he'll actually
end up buying the company but either way
it looks like something crazy about to
happen so we'll get into all of that
joining us tonight this wonderful friday
is julia song
do you want to grab your mic you want to
introduce yourself hello they found me
outside
they brought me in that's correct um hi
everyone
this is julia um so
yeah
what do you do that's it that's it yeah
you don't do anything
uh
so uh you can follow me on twitter
twitter at rio jules song but basically
i write i drew a lot of commentary on
politics based on my experience
doing some activism in brazil and how
the you know the socialists take over
using some of my experience my mother
was an attorney for the opposition party
so we had a lot of we suffered a lot of
political persecution things went
downhill and i decided to fight back i
moved here to the u.s thinking
it's done
but it's not because everything is being
played out just the same
so here i am sharing my wisdom and my
knowledge and my wonderful
looks
well all right thank you very much thank
you for stopping by unfortunately we
also have sheamus yeah i mean i'm sorry
it
balances it out i suppose uh so with
netflix here by the way i think they
could stand to lose a few employees with
uh how their stock is doing so maybe
this is that and again they're just like
we need to fire people yeah
and with the whole i mean i i can't i
mean
netflix is never going to be a company
we can look upon positively after cuties
big mouth yeah um but i am sheamus
coughlin i run a youtube channel called
freedom tunes we just uploaded a cartoon
this past thursday called bro v wade i
think you guys are really going to enjoy
it go over there check it out hit the
notification bell we're going to be
releasing a couple videos next week
about uh about this roe v wade being
overturned and i think you'll think
you'll enjoy those as well uh ian
crossland everybody what's going on good
to see you happy friday let's get
rolling yes it is friday the 13th i'm
very excited it's a silly little date
kind of dumb and i wanted to say too
that netflix has horrible cartoons
seamus has great cartoons we have your
competition there you go yes there you
go i don't know if this is true but i
heard there's going to be a blood moon
lunar eclipse tonight of course there is
is there something i don't know i'm
going to look that up here let's look
that up and while you're looking it up
everyone else can go to
surfinginternetsafe.com to pick up your
virtual private network from virtual
shield with a 50
off lifetime discount a virtual private
network is a basic layer of security for
you as you browse the web so it stops
corporations hackers governments from
stealing your data selling it and it's
you know simple
layer protection like locking your door
locking your windows we don't expect
people to break into our homes but we
still
lock our doors and windows if you go to
surfing internetsafe.com
and get virtual shield their vpn service
is compatible with all devices it allows
you to browse the web safely securely
and anonymously using their global
network of servers and private ips it
lets you browse the web completely
anonymously so big name isps can't
monitor and sell your internet activity
when using their vpn service your
traffic is routed through their secure
and encrypted servers this means that
any restrictions censorship blocks on
your internet are bypassed
it is completely free for 30 days and
available on mac windows iphone ipad
android or chrome virtual shield does
all the work for you your connection
becomes secure private and encrypted it
even secures your wi-fi
personal family and business plans are
are available family plans include 15
devices business plan allows you to add
as many employees as you need virtual
shield will completely encrypt your
wi-fi as i mentioned so again head over
to surfing internet safe shout out to
virtual shield they're the first sponsor
we've ever had they've been with us the
entire time so you want to support
companies that support us back check
them out but don't forget to head over
to timcast.com become a member and
support us directly you will be keeping
our journalists employed and you will
also get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast check that stuff out and don't
forget to smash the like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and let's get into
this first story
from timcast.com netflix adds
anti-censorship section to corporate
culture memo quote if you'd find it hard
to support our content breadth netflix
may not be the best place for you the
streaming service has advised employees
and that's and that's really it that's
the that's the big
smack in the face the document it's
their culture it's their
corporate culture memo whatever
guidelines was originally a 125 slide
presentation created by co-founder reed
hastings uh to regulate the company
without a traditional corporate
structure now it's called netflix
culture seeking excellence and they're
basically saying they've added an
anti-censorship portion to it and
everybody basically assumes about dave
chappelle netflix dumps a ton of money
on one of the most prominent if not the
mo the greatest comedian of all time or
at least he's the goat right
they're gonna make a lot of money on
this and their own employees hurt their
business but you know what else they did
if you watch the dave chappelle special
i forgot which one was called not the
closer it was the one before this where
he makes the uh
sticks and stones i think it was six and
seven where he has this he has that
funny bit where he's like ladies if you
can kill it i can at least abandon it
stuff like that so he also you know
imitated a chinese person and a very
offensive stereotype he went he went for
it
the closer was basically him clearly
you know ruffled up he was basically
defending himself the whole time like
why are people yelling at me so netflix
was like wow
that was not that good they cost us
money if you don't like it get out i
feel like at the corporation there
should be something in their contracts
where if you speak out against the
company i don't know if every
corporation knows this but that you have
there's a recourse that you can be fired
again with no no bailout package or
anything
uh if they don't have that they maybe
they should consider putting that into
their contracts for their employees and
secondly jeremy hamby the quartering
said this earlier today he's reporting
on this as well that they're about to do
a mass layoff i mean they just lost
massive amounts of money they're about
to lay people off so if they can get him
to quit they don't have to pay them
unemployment you know what story i
really love is when uh there's a company
i used to work for that
uh i left and a bunch of employees i
knew there were like we're going to
unionize and i said you realize that
company doesn't make any money right
like it's all investment there's no
profit so if you're getting paid off of
someone else's money and you're not
making any money for them and then you
go to the boss and say i want more money
he's gonna be
get out you're fired there's no
negotiating when you don't make any
money and they don't believe me they're
like no we're gonna get raises and
benefits and i was like dude you need to
go right now and tell them
that you don't want to be a part of that
you love your job and you look for any
opportunity within any of the sister
networks and then sure enough what ends
up happening is they all come and say we
want to unionize and they were like
everyone's fired 300 people just gone
i look my attitude for uh for most
people is like feel unionized if you
want to you know back then i was just
like but just keep in mind what your
negotiating power is so when you have
when you have netflix here's why i bring
this up
these employees
stomp their feet stage walkouts protest
the company they work at what do you
think is going to happen when it comes
time for layoffs like the growth is not
infinite there will come a time when
netflix is hurting netflix is hurting
and they're going to be like okay we got
to lay off 10 percent of this of the
company who should we start with um how
about all of the people that were
complaining causing us bad press and
weren't doing their jobs yeah so this is
a classic case of uh the squeaky wheel
getting the grease for sure and in this
instance it's not something positive
this is where you're like trying to
figure out all right who needs to go who
needs to go needs to go oh right you you
were complaining about this guy who's
gonna make us a ton of money you can get
out don't want you anymore very much a
case of flying too close to the sun
feeling very entitled to everything that
netflix has to offer and like they have
to bow to you they don't turns out which
i think is great
yeah that's a good point i obviously
think collective bargaining can be a
great thing but people have to consider
the value that they're bringing to the
table as well as how profitable the
company they're working for actually is
because oftentimes it does happen that a
business will run without making
anything and the company's completely
sponsored by other people's money or by
loans and so they really can't afford to
give people more sometimes it also
happens to be the case that profit
margins for certain industries are just
razor thin and what you actually have to
do to make more than that is pick a
different industry yeah
and i'm i'm a little bit concerned that
these people are going to go to other
industries and bring the same horrible
mindset and that these industries are
going to count out to them just like
they have in the past little bit
concerning but who knows you know what's
going to happen is netflix is going to
write um amazing recommendations for all
of these employees they want to get rid
of please and it's going to be like they
were so good but you know with the
downsizing it's unfortunate i wish we
didn't have to let them go
and then some other company is going to
be like well looks like everybody really
liked you you're hired suckers
recommendations are such a tricky thing
right because landlords will also
recommend people that they just want to
get rid of to other landlords yeah
they're great no they pay their rent on
time they're never allowed they don't
make a mess of the place
that's a good point i had to give a
recommendation one time and i was like
i'm gonna tell the truth about this
person they should not hire this mf this
person was not good and i don't know if
that person got the job or not but i was
like you need to know what you're
getting into you did the right thing i
think so i think so i don't know yeah i
think it's your responsibility as a
business owner to be honest about your
employees behavior
it's just such a case of social justice
for them to just be like oh we're going
to say super nice things about them so
wherever they end up working that
person's going to be blindsided but by
freaking activism that's not helpful to
any workplace well yeah yeah well go bro
yeah also and again i mean whenever
you're dishonest it's going to cause
problems and if you're dishonest about
something like that you're actually
doing the person more harm than good
because if you're being dishonest with
the people who you're sending them to
there's a higher probability that you
were also being dishonest with them
when you were expressing potential
problems or failing to and so you've
deprived them of an opportunity to grow
this is this is obviously mostly about
dave chappelle yeah but i also just you
know warn people cuties had a big
backlash too
and if netflix is really saying oh we're
not gonna get rid of this we're gonna
artistic expression is so important
yeah that's that's what they were
claiming about cuties where they were to
produce the movie they actually trained
little girls to do sexual dancing that's
like you shouldn't you shouldn't do that
and they also have big mouth which is
just the weirdest show
i don't understand that show can
somebody who's seen it explain it to me
like what's the truth i don't want to
say it you just don't want to say it
like okay it's about children having sex
there you go yeah it's like it's like 12
year olds experiencing puberty but it's
like overly sexualized there's a demon
that sits on the kid's shoulder that's
like a sex demon i've only seen it once
that's real yeah that's really
disturbing and there's and there's overt
sex and like sexual acts with little
kids how's that allowed high school
seriously i mean south park south park
had a few jokes like that in its run
like a handful but this is a show just
based about that like that's all it is
but you know i guess the one thing is
south park never sh like
south park has done some really over the
over the line jokes of course but this
show i remember uh i was hanging out
some dudes you know set some party and
they had netflix on and the show was on
and then i'm like what is this and then
i'm watching it
i don't even want to say i i don't even
think for a family friendly show i can
explain what they showed like i can't
say it well
there was materials that were shown from
a male
like on a child and i'm just like i
i don't know why you guys are watching
this what is this that's like not even
edgy that's just full-on perversion
that's disgusting jail
jail yeah that's why i'm like netflix
censor that one yeah i i don't always
agree with you tim but it's one of those
shows man when i walked into the room my
friend was watching and i was like this
is
ridiculous
why and i walked out i wouldn't let
myself be near it while it was on it was
disturbing i'd be willing to bet that if
we showed on the on on this show a clip
from big mouth
we'd get taken out we get taken down so
this strikes me as genderqueer the show
because you can't read that in front of
a school board meeting and they're like
oh please shut up we have kids at home
watching this so if you were to show
this on you know youtube they'd be like
oh my gosh you cannot show that well
it's on netflix there was one
controversy where you two netflix
uploaded a clip from the show that shows
two pre-pubescent girls fully nude what
walking through a bath house with a
bunch of other naked women that are all
singing and dancing about being naked
and what what they argued was no no it's
good because it's body positivity it's
like to teach little girls to like their
bodies and i was just like i don't know
if you need to actually
show all of this you know to to
give someone a message about it it seems
like an excuse i mean you want to teach
little kids about their bodies that's
the parent's job you put a tv show with
little girls parading around 47 year old
men are going to be watching it too
yeah that pisses me off i feel like with
netflix though
they get so much flack from everybody
like they get flak from everything that
they do they're getting flak so they're
telling the employees like if you guys
say anything it's going to add because
they lost so much money with their their
stock value and all of that so it's like
don't come out don't even with the
twitter stuff it's like the the
the inflated numbers i feel like they're
trying to keep people from doing uh
whistleblowing or doing anything that
could potentially have an impact because
they're so sensitive to bad press right
now
and i i think it's just a weak move i
guess
yeah the free speech argument is there
like oh these employees should be able
to say whatever they want about their
parent company and you know what they
are legally they are but the company has
the right to fire them and if you don't
like where you're working and you want
to complain about that company publicly
then you probably shouldn't be working
there well yeah i mean also it's one of
these things where
you can
have conversations with people who are
above you in the company or voice or
criticisms within it is sort of a
strange thing to go outside of the
organization and and start trashing at
that point it's like why are you working
there why do you work for these people
you think are horrible are you doing
something to try to change it on the
inside and if that's not working again
why are you still there i feel like it's
a
to me that raises all kinds of red flags
like if you're telling
outside people that you hate the company
what are you doing during your company
hours that could potentially like are
you taking away stealing information are
you not doing your job like you're
supposed to are you eating up your hours
like that's to me to me i feel well a
lot of the contracts that you sign the
companies as well
they're like you have to go through
um our public relations uh office you
can't if the media reaches out to you
you can't talk to them right the social
media policy so
i mean it makes sense um
i just it's sort of like something that
i guess people never thought the
companies would actually follow through
but i guess netflix is like
honestly i'm glad that they are because
people have gotten so unprofessional i
don't care where i work i work for a lot
of different places i had a lot of
horrible work experiences never
complained about the company that i
worked for nor should you let's let's
jump over to wokeness and media we have
this tweet from
nathan grayson over the washington post
who says he's a video game reporter i
suppose that means that he will provide
us information reporting on video games
oh however he tweeted and before i
before i get into it nathan buddy you
made it congratulations here's what you
were hoping for
you are now getting talked about he says
shannon liao and i reached out to over
20 major video game companies about
whether they intend to speak up in favor
of reproductive rights or provide
monetary aid to employees just a few
said yes most said nothing at all
this is literally the wendy's meme
this is the way this is a wendy's sir
yeah it's like this
bro i i just i would love to see this
guy like pull up to a wendy's and
they're like well i'm going to land and
i tank your order do you support
reproductive rights sir this is a
wendy's i'll take it as a no can you
write it down they're not that far from
that point
we're gonna see articles from
journalists like i went to the wendy's
on 2nd street and they would not give a
strong stance in favor of reproductive
rights we should legit do this
a good skit let's go to wendy's
just for the purpose of being like do
you support women's reproductive rights
and the guy's going to be like i'm 16
and i just make cheeseburgers like
excuse me how does super mario feel
about roe v wade being overturned he
actually includes that comment in there
so he has this big twitter thread
and it and it's fascinating too let me
say something on the culture wars this
guy
likes the fact that we're talking about
it he doesn't care about us he doesn't
care that he's not reporting this is the
future of what these media companies
will be
the washington post has become kotaku
this you know just just gamer gate
leftist woke media and it works for them
and they're going to get the people who
care about the people who don't like
right wingers or whatever and so he
doesn't care what we say about him like
do you think i care when they write
about me or whatever i ignore all of it
i don't care like people are chatting
and smack talking me and i'm like i can
only read so much this guy doesn't care
he's getting attention it's working for
him and this is what the culture war has
become
so it goes on to mention that bungie
says they're for it blah blah blah and
then he starts talking about people are
suddenly losing their minds over this
piece so let me spell out the rationale
behind it game companies were extremely
vocal following george floyd's murder
covert born anti-asian hate silence here
is telling it suggests broader
disingenuousness
i'm sorry
i like started laughing while i was
drinking what a ridiculous thing like
is it firstly to want these companies to
comment on in the first place but but
secondary like does he think that these
companies just became right-wing yes
they started becoming conservative like
well look this is one where we really
are more conservative he he quote
tweeted ben shapiro who said in which
activists masquerading as journalists
call up companies and ask why taylor
swift's silence is so definite
he says lol lol that's he likes it yeah
he says if fox decides to do a segment
on me my one request is that they use
this picture
and this is the point this guy's not a
reporter he is an activist his reporting
makes literally no sense i mean it's the
wendy's meme am i gonna am i gonna say
well wendy's once had an lgbtq twitter
icon they have not said anything about
abortion it's deafening
like when they they everybody all the
companies were putting their uh profile
pictures black for like after george
floyd and then if a company wouldn't do
that everybody lost their minds but i
feel like it's the same thing as as
taylor lorenz is bad uh
sort of like bad intention disguised as
journalism where she was like oh uh the
reason why i had to expose the lips of
tick-tock girl is because she could have
been a russian asset okay well you found
out she wasn't a russian asset and you
still expose her so it's like oh uh the
reason why i'm doing this with the video
games is because they did that and so
they're always gonna find an excuse to
their bad journalism or activism or
whatever but it's like
shut up already
i mean
sure sonic the hedgehog isn't a russian
accent you can't be sure so if you look
just to the right on twitter you have
gaming trending blizzard announces
king's diversity space tool a
measurement device to help identify how
diverse a set of character traits are
which is planned to be released
internally starting the summer here's
what's gonna happen oh gosh it is meme
come to life the next triple a game that
comes out every character is going to be
a trans disabled no
furry
please no no yeah it's going to happen i
noticed a person of color new games were
they uh
where they were it said when you pick
your gender instead of man or woman now
you can pick like type one type two
other things in elven ring it says like
type a type b or something like type one
type two like you're choosing your
character's form of diabetes no no i
thought this was funny i called them
sexist i tweeted about i was like you
know eldon ring is sexist because the
female body type is number two what it
should have been type one and type a
seriously female i mean it's called male
or female woman you have man or woman
like why do you think it's a secondary
why they have to add on extra letters to
describe it that reminds me of that uh
jk rowling um
stuff where she was always like nobody
asked her anything and she was like
dumbledore was gay
that was gay yeah that's that meme so
why why do i care that if sonic is
having something with tails like
stop it i don't i don't want to see it i
don't want to think about it so ian i
will give you a a linguistic lesson
thank you woman comes from whitman the
original uh i think it's old english i'm
not sure and it used to be males were
wormen and so there were two distinct
words worm and whiffman and then due to
i think what they said was
the the the work role being masculine
men just started saying men instead of
worming because if they would say man in
reference to a human being in general
but only men were around men just
eventually became the default for male
or whatever the other night i was
thinking i think the word woman needs a
new word because it women's
birthing person no it's something
simple one syllable
an extra aberration of the word man like
menstrual man you know just like a new
word that sounds cool
it sounds metal you know it's crazy flip
flip yeah you're on you're picking in
the right space
the this oh i see it everywhere like um
so i'm originally from brazil i lived
there for 20 years of my life so
whenever people say
uh latinx
it it
like it it hurts me a little bit i guess
i get the i get the eye twitch
because yeah in in uh latin languages
the male version is also the i guess
unisex version of a word so whenever
you're referring to somebody that you
don't necessarily know their gender
you would use the male form so
it it
it hurts me
i'm sorry well i i understand that as a
flip you may be more comfortable exactly
well and this is it's not is it like
what did the did the left go into the
latino community ask do you guys want a
new name no they just decided to name
them because they think they have
ownership over the entire group of
people because that's what renaming
someone or something means it means you
own them and they see them as political
pawns not as human beings and they are
political pawns who belong to them in
their estimation so that's why they get
to decide what they're called this is
why everyone has to resist the term this
is why i said uh like it was a year a
year ago that the gender neutral uh
pronoun for everyone is flourbo i like
that yeah it's soft it reminds me of
flubber with that robin williams you
know it was fun childhood memories
nobody can complain about that there's
an o at the end that's too masculine
yeah that's too masculine
it's uh i was looking up non-binary in
spanish and it's nobinaria and nobinario
yeah
it's insane i wish they would stop that
but they don't so it's like we already
have a word for that we already have a
way of saying it why why don't you just
ask us instead of pushing it like who
came up with this well they they did
they they conducted studies they asked
people they're like do you like the term
latinx blood latinas
what makes sense well they should ask
women what they think of the word
whimsical because everyone hates it no
one's gonna use it nobody asks me any
any exactly like
this this uh polls and stuff like that
everybody's like oh somebody nobody
asked me nobody ever called me and asked
me
do you do you want this dude like it's
i've never been asked about a pole
listen you you need to understand that
the um
being
a morbidly obese millennial woman with
pink hair inside of your head shaved
grants you a kind of
intelligence that you just know what's
what's better for
the oppressed people it's the color of
the hair it makes kids want to listen to
them because they like bright colors
yeah brainwashing yeah it is it is it is
crazy how you see this stuff in schools
where it's like they're like what gender
are you and cisgender is black and white
and then it's like you know trans is a
bunch of colors and it's like pride and
rainbows and they're like if that if you
want to be fine if you want to be the
boring black and white color
fine by the way i want to bring
something really fun up here uh that
validates everything we're saying so
fantastic but according to pew research
76 of latinos surveyed had never heard
the term yes le tinx uh of those who
heard it in in totality so of of the 100
percent of people who were asked if they
had heard the term only three percent
said that they used it 20 said they knew
it and didn't use it 76 percent said
they never heard did they break it down
between men and flibs uh i can double
check
i can double check on that
but it doesn't appear so i believe they
did break it down a little bit maybe in
another poll where it showed that
college-educated women were the only
group that liked it and they used it i
was like this is in no way surprising
educated flips yeah
oh you're right well flip is a word you
gotta be careful but we'll figure it out
female liberals
yeah i heard latinx libya calm down
i love that or what is it latinx or
to know latinx sounds sounds weird like
it inks like i don't know like
that's what i thought like it reminds me
of like
tinkle so yeah tinkle this latino tinker
licks um i heard if people if people
want if people demand you give them a
special name that they demand to be
called
like
just make up one that doesn't sound good
yeah i'm back i won't use the one that
offends you but i'll i'll choose one for
you bloath i'm so glad first the first
amendment is free speech because people
make up words and they want me to start
using their lexicon it's i feel so bad
for the canadians man that bill c-16 and
then i think other bills have been
passed that is like forcing people to
use certain words so they don't offend
other people you ready for this you
don't hold on to that inks
not yet but you can change my mind
you guys ready for this one yes
sexual harassment investigation launched
into three middle schoolers wrong use of
pronouns
they were charged under title nine
according to the school these three kids
because they refused to say they them
one kid actually stood up to says quote
she had been screaming at one of
brandon's friends to use proper pronouns
calling him a profanity and his friend
is very soft-spoken it kind of just sunk
down into his chair braden finally came
up defending him saying he doesn't have
to use proper pronouns it's his
constitutional right to not use you
can't make him say things
so apparently these kids were in trouble
the mom found out
this is in wisconsin they're saying that
because the kids refuse to use the
pronouns they're getting they're getting
heavily penalized we also know the fbi's
investigating parents who are opposing
this stuff
um
it was uh
uh who was it
i'm forgetting who tweeted this
maybe i'm forgetting the guy's first
name um mcintyre oh aaron aaron yeah
sorry forget your name dude he tweeted
that that the soft power they use to
bring the stuff into schools
will become hard power
and i'm like
it is hard power they are going to the
kids they're screaming at them swearing
at them and if the kid's like i'm not
going to say it then they get charged so
i don't know what that means when they
said they were charging them
apparently the news says an
investigation
let me read they filed a complaint
against them
uh an investigation was launched a title
nine complaint was filed against them so
what what is it gonna what does that
mean she says i received a call from the
principal letting me know that i was
going to be receiving an email with
sexual harassment allegations against my
son
she says uh the investigating said he's
allegedly charged with sexual harassment
for not using proper pronouns
so here's this is what i'm saying look
if anybody says
this word is offensive and you have to
use this word i'll say that word's
offensive to me so how about i use this
word which is neither and we'll call
them blows bloof you're a bloof also
keep in mind these are the people these
are the people who are saying that
groomer is a needlessly harsh term to
describe adults insisting upon having
secret sexual conversations with
children then they turn around and say
not using someone's pronoun is sexual
harassment
dude this
these kids are national heroes that
stood up to this i don't know what the
situation is around what they if there
was a fight beforehand if part of this
is because there was violence involved i
really don't know the whole story but
you cannot bully people into using your
language in this country
well apparently you can you can try but
it's going to get national attention
you're going to look like the bad guy
for doing it
i hope so guys spaghetti gate
no they have language police in france
so
i'm in france they i'm pretty sure they
do but i'm in canada yeah yeah i might
just say french-speaking canada there
you go correction is that quebec so in
i think it was in montreal
you have to have at all the stores
french is the big word and then english
is small so they're like language police
make sure and there's an italian
restaurant selling spaghetti and they
got fined because they were like you
didn't put the french word and they were
like spaghetti
so like
that they're the bad guys like when
you're trying to tell people you can't
you have to speak a certain way you have
to use certain words
you typically are it is frowned upon
right yeah big time i don't know if it's
like just me or if it seems like
they're coming so hard after kids like
even with the video game stuff it's like
leave the kids alone why do you care
it's like
at this point i'm like
don't make me tap the sign like people
are like right yeah
i was like don't make me tap the sign um
it's like everything there just just
leave the kids alone leave the kids
alone remember that song that that told
the parents to leave hey teachers leave
those kids alone yeah it's a good song
do you remember that one song where they
said we'll convert your children yeah
yeah it was a san francisco choir yep
gay men's choir i think it was and this
is this is the golden rule of the left
right or one of the many rules
they will scoff at the idea that they're
doing something call you paranoid for
thinking that they're doing something
and then a few years later they go
i was doing it the whole time as if
they're cheeky or edgy and it's like no
we knew that that's what it is we know
what you're up to we have how many years
ago is it five years now when jordan
peterson yeah we came out about that
that bill
c-16 c-16 look what's happening here in
the united states
i mean this is people people keep
believing it's not going to get worse
and i'm saying to people
this is this this is what i said you
know a couple weeks ago
would you rather
have a job
and your kid is with groomers for eight
hours a day or be homeless with your kid
i mean i i i'm not telling you which one
is the right choice i don't have kids
i'm saying like this is basically what's
happening there are people like i can't
speak up i can't do anything about it
i'll lose my job
my kids got to go to school otherwise i
have no one to watch them it's like okay
i hear you i think i mean the groomers
have your kids and they're doing this to
them but you know i think they should
come up with a system of like
neighborhood uh homeschooling moms where
like you'd have somebody let's say uh
within the neighborhood there is one or
two moms that
chose to not work or to stay at home and
then the kids around that neighborhood
go to that uh mom's house and spend the
day and learn like their mom's already
homeschooling her kids so one or two
other students is not gonna make a
difference but at the same time it's
gonna make it easier for people to just
have their kids homeschooled instead of
sending them to school like i
don't have kids but i feel like if i do
i'm i'm always so busy and so i
procrastinate a lot and you know all the
video game and dragon ball but
to be honest with you i i think i i have
to make time to
homeschool because i i just don't see
myself sending my kids to these places
like come back
oh you know mommy um i found out i'm gay
i'm like
shut up joshua you're three oh my gosh i
love this also you don't want to play
video games because they they haven't
commented on roe v wade so yeah
here's the important thing
in this story
when the mother was asked some say this
could show rabideau and her son are
against the lgbtq plus community she
said not at all not at all my children
have been raised to love everybody
equally you know what i'd say
i'd say i don't know about any of that
but if this is what they're doing i
guess apparently but not a single you
had that um matt walsh
was it was it the matt walsh thing on um
on dr phil yes
yeah yeah yeah they but but they had
they had this um
instance where this woman was like we're
not we're not against the lgbt community
you know we're not at all it's our kids
it's like dude
if that's what they're hiding behind and
that's encompassed in it then i guess
if they're if they're grooming your kids
if they're screaming at your kids if
they're using law to go after your kids
and then someone says do you oppose the
community i'd say doing this yes yeah
well joe rogan came out about it i have
a headline from the daily wire that says
rogan blasts people upset about quote
groomer term here's what's more
important not having people groom your
effing kids under the guise of i'm an
lgbtq educator looking good for him did
you guys see the viral genkuger was
trending earlier yeah and i did a
segment talking about it because i'm
just like i feel like it's bait
what he what joe rogan said was there
are groomers in schools
you know they're creepy weirdos they
they beat it in front of kids it happens
all the time
you got kids being groomed how many of
them are hiding behind lgbtq
so then genter goes not a single person
has ever you know beat off in front of
kids and then said they were lgbtq so
that no one got mad and i'm like i don't
recall joe actually saying those things
so gent did this performative outrage
where he said something that never
happened or joe never claimed so that he
could come out and go after him and this
is the problem having this happening is
people like genkuger don't google search
these things
he didn't even look up because there's
like if you google search teacher
exposes and all that stuff it's insane
how many stories there are about
teachers
just doing these things to kids it's
nuts and then i'm like why would you say
this do you want the world to be better
do you want people to stop abusing kids
let's take the lgbtq thing and just put
it aside for a minute people abuse kids
joe rogan said people abuse kids why why
act like that's not happening
seriously it yeah so everybody start
posting pictures of horses i guess yeah
so
this is this is part of the problem like
let's say we could just completely
separate these two issues out from one
another the groomer teachers from the
lgbtq
issues
even if we could do that what the left
has made abundantly clear
is that if somebody is a sexual abuser
all they need to do is claim some kind
of lgbtq status and the left will do
everything they can to make sure that
story is ignored
not talked about
you know that reminds me of that
transgender woman who went to women's
president you guys say that
and then she got she
whatever this person uh phleb
um
got two women at the prison flips yeah
pregnancy
yeah yeah oh right right
i mean look i i i think the issue is
there is a a cult
that wants to
push their religion on people they're
authoritarian about it
i i don't care what your faith or
ideology is so long as you are
libertarian about it now you can talk
about the things you like but when it
comes to the stuff with kids adult
activities with children then it's just
like no no we don't we don't do that
here and they're advocating for it and
then worse like i'm sure i had
somebody throughout my whole life a
teacher that was gay like i i don't care
they didn't tell me about it i feel like
the only thing that i actually liked
about when teachers told the story about
their lives was the fact that
i was able to you know not pay attention
there's nothing going on there's no
class i just do my own thing text my
friends but it's like to me it's it's
not relevant for my education when you
tell me about your wife your kids or
your partner or whatever i just think
that as a time of like okay now i get to
goof off with my friends and blah blah
blah like it's it's not necessary for a
child to be educated for them to know
that you went hiking with your uh gay
partner like
we're gonna we're gonna have some a
couple lefties on the show next week
it's gonna be really really interesting
because i think what happens is
you know we'll be like hey look here's a
really bad story this book genderqueer
has overtly adult activities described
in images maybe that shouldn't be for
kids and then all of these left-wing
podcasters come out and they're like
you're banning books you're banning
books and i'm like okay when they're
banning books based on the ideas i can
understand that but they're like trying
to remove sexual imagery
why are you defending why are you
defending these books why is the
washington post the new york times and
all these left persons i will i will
love to talk to them about it we should
get a copy of those books too so we can
show them in person don't make me tap
this because we can't because we can't
show it on youtube yeah that's true well
let's talk about the chain what's hap
speaking of censorship
we got this story from tim cast elon
musk is still committed to twitter
purchase after announcing deal was on
hold musk said he would defeat the spam
bots or die trying a cause for due
diligence to discover the true daily
active user numbers in the deal i'm
going to give you the quick version i
think elon musk knew there was fraud i
believe twitter it's possible has has
defrauded its shareholders we know that
they've lied i'm sorry i'm sorry
we know they've published false user
numbers on more than one occasion
they've apologized for it
let me show you something interesting if
we go to socialblade and look at little
ole me we can see that on april 26th i
gained just about 20 000 followers the
next day about 40 000. next day about 47
000. gaining all of these followers
strange right at the same time barack
obama loses three hundred thousand at
the same time katy perry loses two
hundred thousand
why are
celebrities and left and progressives
losing followers but people on the
libertarian freedom whatever right side
are gaining followers i'll tell you what
i think
that's here's the dates the 26th 27th to
28th the 29th was a friday
monday was the second and what news
broke on the second
twitter estimates fake accounts comprise
less than five percent of users filing
on may second okay is what they say
in a filing on monday may 2nd
they say it was five percent here's my
here's my opinion after looking at all
of this information
the week prior they reinstated as many
writing accounts as possible to create
human users and banned as many bots as
possible to reduce the number of bots so
they could bring the number of bots per
user way way down i think elon musk knew
they were doing that i think
he's forcing them to give him the data
now that he's locked in this deal or
lose a billion dollars
and if they give him the information on
all these users he can come out and be
like they defrauded me they defrauded
you and they defrauded all the
shareholders i think twitter
believes in a healthy conversation and
they're trying to socially engineer this
country and people who use twitter
around the world by making it seem like
pro-america and libertarian values are
not prominent
and woke leftist ideas are
so they create fake accounts or someone
does and they ban counts that are
pro-america then the switch the flip
happens we watched it happen
then they released the report on their
bots elon's going to get that data
because they have to reveal it to him
and then we'll see what happens yeah i'm
curious what his next step would be
after that is this just something that
he uh does to expose them or does he try
to come in and alter the price maybe
twitter blows up maybe it just it's gone
i mean i don't know that this is true
right what i'm saying is if you look at
the fact that leftist loss followers
libertarian right manga what everyone
call it gained followers that's that's
that's algorithmic people have tried
claiming the left is leaving and the
right's joining no no that's ridiculous
because if you look at the data as i
pointed out the last time we talked
about it on monday the day they
announced the deal was happening
no one joined twitter they're lying
that's not true the data does not
suggest that the data suggests twitter
made weird algorithmic changes and then
the next week monday they issued their
filing on bot accounts
clearly they were manipulating the
numbers
scandal it's a scandal
it's it's john got him
i agree with you actually i think what
you said is mostly true i would say if i
was newsguard uh i don't know that he
knew they were about the fact politifact
thank you i don't know that he knew that
there were bots i think he highly
he he thought that there were he had a
good feeling a hunch i'll tell you my my
greater theory
one day elon musk is on twitter
and he's like i really like this pebble
and b i'm going to tweet it to them and
then he does and then all of a sudden it
goes
new notification and he looks and it's
himself
trying to convince himself to engage in
a crypto scam
because you ever see those the first
thing he thought of was time travel and
he's like hasn't been invented yet he's
like could i have come back from the
future to sell bitcoin to myself yes but
unless let me check
and then he like does some math and he's
like
this is a bot and then he probably
complained and they did nothing
so there's a really famous uh
like biting scam where elon musk bots
will tweet at people to get him to give
crypto
elon probably was like this is me stop
and he says okay i'm gonna get rid of
this stuff so i think he knows something
was going on i also think
elon probably saw the manipulation with
sock puppet accounts a stock puppet
account is when one person runs multiple
accounts
i'm willing to bet
the left runs tons of sock puppet
accounts
where one activist will have 20 accounts
and they'll spam you to make it seem
like everyone is dog piling you and
hates you you'll say something and then
you'll get 50 responses where they're
like you're ugly you're gross you're
stupid you're lame to try and trick you
and force you to changing your opinion
then twitter bans people on the right so
no one can come to your aid i think i
think that's what's happened that's my
opinion on what's happening so you're
saying that i'm not ugly stupid and lame
like
is it john
no you're not i'm the exception yeah
it's it's a form of grooming
what they do is
when 30 people tell you hey man you know
concerned trolling like i'm a big fan
but i think you're not right on this one
you should change your opinion and then
the only thing you see is people saying
you're wrong about it weaker-minded
people might be like okay i better i
better change my position on this they
call it al groom rhythmic
i don't know if i said that right i
tried yeah you gotta write it down first
you know i noticed something when i was
in college which is that when i got
people who were
really
outwardly left-leaning
alone and had conversations with them
where we weren't with other students um
they would generally
say things that you would not expect a
left winger to say so maybe i'd you know
run into them somewhere outside of
school or we would just be chatting
outside of class and whenever current
events came up they would almost
inevitably say something about any given
issue that
that would basically get someone
screamed up by any other left-winger for
not being left-wing enough
and they'd even say things like yeah i'm
going to be honest like i do think the
left is kind of gone off the deep end in
certain ways and part of me wondered if
that was because
they were being sincere about their
values because they were surrounded by
other left-wing people
part of me also wondered if that was
because they understood or got the vibe
that they were talking to a more
conservative person and they're just
social chameleons who need to fit in
with whoever they're having a
conversation with i don't know but in my
experience
it it's funny in my experience people
are yeah even left-wing people are not
as far to the left when they're not in a
group it's like as soon as they get
around other people they're mao
uh but when they're by themselves
they're they're like they turn into dave
rubin i think they're scared
they're being groomed with like the the
language and everything that you see
like the media so they're scared of like
not going all the way because if not
then what would they side with they will
side with
the maggot king the the ultra mega the
fascists the the the kkk so it's like
they feel like they have to constantly
move
further to the left
to be able to match that even though it
may not match it uh what they think but
it's like for the bigger cause because
if they don't do it if they don't stay
together if they don't stay united
then um you know big bad orange guy is
gonna be back in the white house and
then everybody is gonna uh be put in
camps or something so they have to stick
together and to me you know
that that's it's like zombies yep yep
and it is a fallacy to think that in
order to not be part of group a you have
to join another group you don't have to
join a group absolutely the funniest
thing i love a lot is when these lefties
will post on twitter they'll be like i'm
not in a brainwashed cult like you are
and it's like they're the group that
voted in lockstep to fund the war in
ukraine and then the other side of this
is
former liberals traditional liberals
conservatives you've got the far right
you know laissez-faire capitalist types
you've got libertarian centrists like
there's this big eclectic group of
people who all disagree with each other
who are sitting in rooms and having
conversations you're all in the room all
patting each other on the back saying
they're the cult
i went on facebook a couple nights ago
i've got a very interesting social media
array because i uh most of my facebook
friends from 2007 89 when i was in la as
an actor very liberal now most of my
twitter followers are people that watch
this show so it's more or less
conservative i don't want to put you in
a box guys you're whatever you want to
be but when i go on on twitter or on
facebook they're like you know
pro-choice when it comes to the abortion
thing and they're like they think oh
that's just what they think and it's the
same kind of crap when we're on the show
and we're talking about them whatever
whenever it comes up about they it's the
same terminology and the same weird that
the people don't even know who they are
they're just using this term except
we're right of course you always we
always think we are don't we no but we
are well everyone thinks they're the
good guy man let's be careful we are
about categorizing other people the data
has repeatedly shown that moderates and
conservatives consume media from the
left and know the left-wing argument but
the left doesn't do the other i think
there are instances in history where
like the nazis were a radical left
leftist organization i've heard you know
and they were indoctrinating kids and
the people that stood against that
turned out to be on the right side of
history it is possible that
and i think a lot of when it comes to
objective morality a lot of what we're
talking about is real like it's
important to protect the children let me
let me uh clarify this point as to why
we're right and they're not
you have as i mentioned traditional
liberals people like you know me i used
to i voted for obama 08. i was from the
city and now i'm like hey man i don't
like this woke stuff i want free speech
you have devout catholics like sheamus
very pro-life conservative and we
disagree on a lot of those elements but
we agree on so much more when it comes
to what's reality what's true you have
journalists like matt taibi
a liberal outright who's like yeah this
ukraine stuff with joe biden is messed
up you have glenn greenwald a
progressive you have jimmy dore how is
it that all of these people from actual
economic far left to laissez-faire
capitalist anarchists or people like
people like luke rydkowski all can can
come together and agree and point at
the left and say they're wrong
as i mentioned when it when you look at
that voting bloc for ukraine war funding
and every single democrat is voting yes
on one of the largest war packages ever
and the republicans are all in
disagreement i'm like something is wrong
when the anti-war progressive leftists
like aoc and the squad are voting in
lockstep for war
they are a cult yeah it's the liberal
economic order and let me tell you ian
you say they say the same thing about us
i i completely agree with similar
terminology it's like it's identical
pretty much it's hard to tell who i
thought they were talking about they
like what we were last night i'm like oh
my god except we were right you know why
covington jesse smallett russiagate
ukraine gate ghost of kiev trayvon
martin george floyd the list goes on
military industrial complex has
controlled the media and if you don't
know that then you're you're getting
sucked up into it i don't even know if
it's that you know i don't know what's
going on i think twitter was playing
weird manipulation engineering games the
fact is i remember i had this moment in
you know 2018 and i'm thinking you know
i watch these lefty these left wing
presenters and they're saying the exact
same thing and then i'm like but that's
weird
they're wrong about the covington kids
well that's weird bill maher a week
after the story was debunked comes out
and still maintains the lie well that's
weird russiagate was debunked and
they're still saying it was true
they called rand paul a russian agent
again it's just the lies the
misinformation the manipulation they set
up a disinformation czar this woman
who's published repeated false
information and she wants the right to
control the flow of information so i'm
sorry if you've got an eclectic bunch of
people with all differing world views
and differing political opinions but we
can see what's true and what's not you
have another side that believes every
single lie every time i guess why i
brought it up and you know this when i
did it because what you're saying shame
is people when they're in that group
they do become radicalized but when
they're alone and you communicate with
them people aren't so crazy like people
kind of get together and can understand
so like that's why i'm reticent to say
they because when that person is over
here they're we and and it's you know
they get it it's the funniest thing is
man when i was arguing on facebook with
some people
and i said it's the weirdest thing if
michael malus points this out a lot if
you disagree with anything that is part
of their tribe they immediately assume
you're a trump supporting far-right maga
cult or whatever
and it's like i've actually commented on
people's posts agreeing with them and
they'll immediately say
it's it's the joke someone's like i like
pancakes and i'll be like you know the
interesting thing about pancakes is they
have a lot of carbs and
so you're a waffle person waffles are
about i never said i liked waffles dude
so when i comment on someone's post
about pro-life
they'll make they'll make a point about
conservatives and i'll say
i don't think that's the actual
conservative argument the response i get
is you want to control women's bodies
and put them in chains and i'm like
i don't want to do any of that i don't
understand
it's a cult bro are there
ultra maga trump cultists of course do
they have any institutional power no are
they that are they are they relatively
large in number not really yeah so what
we'll see with the left is they'll take
very basic concepts which legitimately
are binary such as sex and they'll try
to break it up into a million different
gradients and say it exists on a
spectrum when it does it then when it
comes to politics they'll basically say
it's binary either you're with us or
you're some far-right trump supporter
you're also a nazi there's there's no
room for any kind of gradient there on
their own side they sort of try to get
into like some nuance because
they'll claim that you know someone like
bernie sanders is really a moderate and
so we have this very vast spectrum on
our own side even though they're really
only catering to like 10 of the
population in totality when you're
looking at progressives they were
manufacturing public support i think
that um
it's sort of like uh
something that there there's a third
component to this which is you have the
the right and you have the left but you
also have the globalists which they owe
alliance to neither the left nor the
right so they sort of like co-opted
the liberal and the progressive movement
and everything that they do is according
to the globalist agenda like they want
you know no borders they want no there's
no that um
they want to sort of like in everything
everything the the global supply chain
whatever it is more
uh trade with china whatever and a lot
of these things that they have been
pushing is not
um not something that the left would
have wanted
even five to three years ago or even two
months ago but they feel that they have
to keep pushing it because they have to
meet the globalist
sort of like
end goal and hopefully leftists and and
liberals and classic liberals they're
going to start
realizing that um
like stop it they're using it
i think they will
the economy is going to force people to
evolve classic liberals are already out
because classic liberal is a right-wing
position tradition traditional liberals
were social liberals so they were like
center left and there's like there's
like a little bit of a difference but
it's like you know they're both centrist
i think these people uh on the left
aren't
feeling like they have to lock it walk
in lockstep with like the davos group or
anything
it's zombies you know like we were
mentioning the young turks they just
make they make stuff up they lie all the
time maybe it's inept ineptitude maybe
they're just like this look at clicks i
mean if you look at their videos the
thumbs down are crazy like 50 60 percent
i'm like how do you view those still
because i don't have a plug-in oh cool i
can't rationalize it like i can't
understand to be i'm trying to me i'm
thinking they're being brainwashed the
the globalists at the top are like
pushing propaganda and media and
brainwashing these people because i
can't rationalize how you would you know
like these things for kids how you would
you know
uh come after kids like that like to me
if if you were to put me in a time
machine like 10 years ago and you showed
me that i'll be ready to you know start
a revolution and i'm not even you know
so it's to me it's like
go ahead no no no no no continue
continue i'm sorry i just wanted to say
it's sort of like how how quickly the
needle is moving
and it's it's just out of control
um so i have to find like a way to
rationalize this behavior like why
they're doing this
and and i don't know i don't have that
that word liberal i don't want to give
that power to that word because it is
post-modernist i'm i'm i'm trying to
understand i'm not an expert of
post-modernism it's the idea that you'd
say i'm a human i'd be like no i'm
actually a embodiment of cells and
they're like no i'm actually in energy
field you're describing none of them
yeah that i was i went through that i'm
like out of the cult now i was in la as
the actor getting ready to be the next
big thing it was disgusting and then
they were all over me sexually it was so
gross
and jordan peterson has talked a lot
about post-modernism he points the
finger at it it's a confusing idea which
is why it hasn't caught as much hot
traction as it needs to
and it's a social movement that started
in the mid-20s mid 19th cen 20th century
basically yeah i just wanted to issue a
small correction to myself earlier i
described them as ten percent of the
population according to pew research
they're six percent but even that figure
isn't perfect because as i'm looking at
how they define it when they talk about
the progressive left they say 88 of
people on the progressive left say that
greater social acceptance of tran of
people who are transgender is a good
thing for the us i mean for only 88 of
them to be saying that when the type of
progressive leftists were talking about
would say
yeah 88 of people who would be who would
fall into this progressive left category
which they say makes up six percent of
the public twelve so myself
yeah and so that's what i'm saying so
this this progressive left group this is
a very small group of people because of
that six percent of the public
only 88 of them this group defined as
progressive left say that more
transgender acceptance is good for
society whereas my understanding is the
progressive leftists we're talking about
would say anyone who answered that
question is anything other than yes is
not a progressive in fact they're far
right let me pull up this story this
one's funny we got it from business
insider biden used the term ultra maga
after six months of research now
republicans have put it on t-shirts
they can't meme
that's like during 2015 and 16 there was
a subreddit called the left can't meme
and it i mean it's just reality the left
could not meme so they banned all of the
big pop prominent you know meme channels
instagram had a huge purge
and then along popped up these really
generic
left-wing meme channels and it was just
so obvious that it's astro turfed this
is what happens when they try ultra maga
and now they're selling t-shirts with it
because it's hilarious here's my
favorite biden calls trump the great
manga king
why did he think anyone would be upset
about that that's amazing
yeah i put that on my on my twitter as
my twitter uh name the great magic king
yeah
joe biden is you know he's leading a
rally where he's trying to get people to
hate the right and he goes these these
right-wingers these really cool awesome
nice people everywhere they're just like
the coolest guys ever and and i think
they shouldn't be in office but they're
really smart and great those ultra mega
that kick is like everything that the
light touches you're going to build a
wall around it again building a wall
around everything the hyenas are not
sending their best okay
when it comes to a culture war if you
want to call it this thing culture war
you can't if you use your opponent's
language you've lost so that's what
biden just did i think i think you're
right in many ways so what the
conservatives have been doing for years
which has been extremely painful is
they've been trying to use left-wing
terminology against the left and they've
been trying to exceed territory to them
so they'll say things like the left are
the real homophobes for example now
groomers that we have been using the
term groomer which is effective and
accurate
and the left has been starting to say no
actually the right of the real groomers
and i'm going you've lost there's
already been several blogs where they
say actually grooming is a good thing
some of them yeah some of them are
saying it's a good thing some of them
are saying the right are the real
groomers so they're but they're
basically accepting the narrative
regardless i saw james lindsay posted
this i think it was james lindsay he was
like
as soon as you get the term they try and
take it from you and now they're like if
you mean grooming my child to be a good
person and loving and accepting then i
stand guilty as charged and it's like
okay you're a girl
okay groomer like
getting them to use this language is is
doing two things in some instances such
as the ones you've mentioned they're
showing their true hand they're saying
oh actually it's a good thing we are in
favor of it in another instance they're
denying it but by denying it they are
reinforcing culturally that it is in
fact a bad thing
and for so long
the right has been doing that with the
left terminology oh i'm not homophobic
oh i'm not transphobic the left are the
real transphobes but the left are the
real racists that's true
i think when you look at like the early
progressive movement yeah absolutely i i
mean even until this day yeah but when
you look at the ideological roots of the
progressive movement yes absolutely i
don't think i just goes all the way back
we've talked about breaking down
are there people associated with the
right whatever that means who are racist
yes in fact there are many are they the
majority no
do they have a lot of power in the
government not really when that one guy
was a steve king
said what's wrong with white nationalism
they booted off all assignments and then
he got he got primary and he's gone now
on the left
are they racist yes they they overtly
advocate for racial segregation in
california they tried to repeal their
civil rights provision from their
constitution they tried to repeal the
non-discrimination provision from their
own constitution it's like dude that is
that is the rule not the exception on
the right it's the exception not the
rule and i think the uh the main reason
is that
moderate individuals two to one move
have aligned more with republicans
simply you look at elon musk's meme
because the left has gone off the rails
so we all stay in the same place
traditional liberals but it's like if i
got to choose between those crazy people
who want to kill babies in nine months
and those guys who are like hey don't
kill babies i'm gonna go with the hate
on kill babies
absolutely and you know i i'd actually
be curious to see if someone could do
some sort of detailed statistical
analysis on exactly how many maniacs
there really are within our society who
would say something like children should
transition their gender i mean if the
progressive left according to pew
research is only six percent of the
general public and even those people as
they've defined progressive left don't
really perfectly fit in with that
category how many people actually
believe in something like yeah but why
trans you know transitioning children
giving sex changes to children pushing
them along to that process uh and we
also see this as something that is being
paired by even the president of the
united states and to your point the
reason people are following along with
it is because in many cases they're
cowardly there are a lot of people who
won't stand up and say that's a
disgusting horrible thing to do
uh because they're afraid of the social
ramifications oh and it's also they're
they're the people that are around would
lambast them if they did it i noticed
with me and you will have talks about
religion and catholicism you know i'm
pretty critical but if we have other
catholic guests on and i say that
everyone comes at me and it's like
almost like i feel bad like as a human
like my i get stressed and like my
genetics are like oh you're not gonna be
as healthy now because of this stress so
like there's an incentive not to speak
out against a group
i noticed uh when i was 13 or 12 or 13
this uh what do they call it um
affirmative action and i realized i was
like 13 1992. wait you mean if i do
better than a guy who's black
for a job interview they'll give it to
him because they need to fill a quota
that's reverse racism and then as i got
older i realized oh that's just racism
yes but then i started to think about
class issues and it's a whole other
nuanced conversation in there but man
did it feel bad
to hear that i i wouldn't get the job
because of my skin color yeah whenever
i'm applying for jobs i get to click a
whole bunch of like little you know tech
marks i'm a woman i'm an immigrant um
latin american i'm this and that i'm
like i i got pretty good chances to get
this job now because i'll look at how
many boxes i clicked i like how these
the leftists are like everybody line up
according to the color of your skin and
the size of your boobs yeah it's like
that's creepy dude
i wanted to bring up real quick there is
a
uh tweet that went viral from this
account called jack califano and it said
the groomer and pedophile thing are the
clearest moment where i've thought oh
wow they're really planning on killing a
lot of people eventually so they're like
make the the left is saying that if you
if you're pushing the groomer and
pedophile thing is because you're trying
to and so this tweet has 61.2
likes as of this time 71.2
k 1000 1000. sorry this is extreme
dehumanizing language designed to
prepare the right-wing fascists to feel
no remorse over genocidal acts of
violence
um
they live in that world yeah and uh the
issue is what
what do you think happens
when you actually have these people
who are going into little girls
bathrooms and taking pictures of them
and then
like
we're going to come to the point where
someone's going to punch something you
can't say nothing about it you can't
call them groomers because now you're a
genocidal a maniac that wants like it it
has nothing to do with tactics it has
nothing it doesn't matter
like we talked about that video game guy
from the washington post who's like you
know i hope they use this picture of me
they literally don't care what any of us
think they're saying this for themselves
doesn't matter and they don't want your
apology either no there's nothing you
can say to them that's why that's why
you know uh
they
there's a tendency for the left not to
interact with the right in any way they
don't care what you think they're lying
they're not interested in telling the
truth and if you go to them and say i'd
like to correct the record they say shut
up so going back to what you were saying
before ian where you're like they say
that we're lying and you know the left
and the right
when when when uh prominent left-wing
personalities take clips from this show
out of context
and then put them up like they did to
you i think media matters did that they
didn't take when you were talking about
the n word they didn't take the full
context into what you were saying they
just try to make it seem like you were
racist
when you go to them and say hey i'd like
to show you what actually happened they
say we don't care we don't they don't
care they're not going to correct it
they'll on on twitter they'll put up a
fake story they love it
they just don't care they're you know
what i think it is
children they're immature they did not
they did not reach adulthood millennials
are a stunted narcissistic generation
certainly there are many millennials
more so like you know i don't know are
you a millennial how old are you um
undisclosed we're going to the break now
yeah when this millennial began what
year i don't know i was like 82 or
something is that yeah yeah i'm 94 so
okay i'm still millennial yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but i
identify as gen z yeah there you go so
so they're i mean there are millennials
who are like responsible adults of
course i'm not saying every single
millennial but what we see i think with
the left is
why are they so cult-like and
zombie-like because they never grew up
they never have they have no strong mind
for for living and being responsible for
themselves
i noticed about i would like to see the
numbers of how wealthy people are if you
want to break you guys know i'm not into
breaking people into categories for the
most part but i will for the sake of
communication the left and the right how
wealthy are the people on the left
relative to the people on the right
because i tend to find that more richer
the wealthier people get except for the
ones at very top manipulating the game
the more wealthy the individual gets the
more conservative they get because
they're happy with the status quo but if
you don't have money you start to freak
out and become revolutionary
i'm not sure i mean i think that at this
point and i couldn't speak to any
specific statistic here other than one
which doesn't perfectly map on but
basically that you're more likely to
support uh intervening on behalf of
ukraine if you have a higher net worth
or make more money uh something along
those lines but you know my point is i
think that the the progressive
especially when you're dealing with like
the like real progressive left we're
talking to people with all the bizarre
theories about gender i would venture to
guess that they are much wealthier as a
group you you don't meet working-class
people who believe that kind of stuff it
started in 2012 the democrats overtook
the republicans as the party of the uh
top four percent of income earners
i i can only assume it's increased since
then but isn't it isn't it isn't it
interesting that's like this the switch
when things started getting weird things
started changing occupy wall street and
then all of a sudden you have post
liberals now voting with republicans why
well the republicans were like we're
going to bring jobs back to the midwest
into michigan and the democrats were
like free trade with china
what's that saying that i i i forgot who
says that uh
but a conservative is a liberal who's
been mugged by reality
so it's like
they live in their own little world and
that's one of the biggest things that i
i try to you know talk in relation to my
activism in my commentary is that
there's a lot of like
bad bad situation that will come from
those policies i mean we've seen it
we're seeing it we're seeing it now and
we're gonna see more and more of that
and
i feel like a lot of this is sort of
like comes from a place of
you're spoiled you don't know what those
policies are actually gonna bring to
america how they're actually gonna pan
out i'm telling you it's not gonna turn
out that way and if you do keep going
down this road
you're gonna get wrecked i don't want
you to get wrecked
let's not do that let's not do this to
the country
and then they're like oh but but it's
going to be different we're going to
wait until like like with socialism
they think that if the government
amasses all this power and all this
money then it's going to be different
this time they're gonna have a better
guy they're gonna have a nicer guy okay
but if you're gonna still have democracy
then later four years from now what if a
bad guy comes in and uses all that money
and all that power to his own evil
intents like you don't think about the
consequences
of all these policies that you're
pushing and how
uh how badly they can affect other
people because you're not gonna be the
first ones to be affected by that like
you you're not the people who are living
you know people in texas they're living
by the border they're seeing all of that
they're seeing the violence in the
communities they're seeing the human
trafficking you're not going to be
affected by that because you're you live
in new york uh you're not the woman
that's being human trafficked you're not
the woman that's being used as a mew so
it's it's easy for you to push these
policies when you're not affected by it
directly so i feel like it sort of like
comes from a place of wealth in a place
of
entitlement because
as they go through reality and they
actually they they get mugged by reality
they tend to become a little bit more
conservative but
um
there is an extent
of
how things can
really really get bad
and i i don't wish that upon america i
wish we would wake up
before that you could but i i i i don't
know if it will you were speaking from
experience you came from brazil you said
at the beginning of the show what did
you what kind of things did you see
there that
made you so sensitive to it so um
i mean everything everything that
um you think about for example you talk
about health care but it's it's sort of
like all of it is in theory but it's not
really it doesn't consider the practice
of like let's say human corruption or
all the other different things that
could add like like in in theory
everything is perfect of course but
let's say you amass all this power all
this money you take it away from me the
individual and you give it to the
government and then what if somebody
comes into the government who's not a
good person like you're not considering
that you're not considering the
corruption you're not considering the
waste you're not considering all these
different things so
um
violence uh corruption
even when they say free health care like
uh yeah i have free health care uh i
didn't like it i mean i didn't like it
is i had to
stand uh around the block on the queue
that by the time you
you get to the door of the hospital it's
you're you're dead so it's like
it's it's sort of like
there is another option there is another
way it's not just
completely not have health care or have
government-sponsored healthcare because
you're gonna have
so much corruption like imagine how what
we're seeing right now with pfizer and
all of that like if you charge me you
guys tell me to shut up if i'm talking
too much but like
if you if i go to the hospital
and you tell me i have to pay 300
i'm okay i'm looking at the receipt
because i worked for those 300 so i want
to make sure what i'm paying
now if that bill never touches my hand
it goes directly to the government the
insurance is building it or the
companies are billing it directly to the
government the government is not going
to look at all of that one by one it's
going to inflate the prices it's going
to create a huge mess in the system a
huge corrupt mess in the system so
why can't instead of
doing that why can't we consider
affordable health care because health
care is not affordable right now we have
these companies uh lobbying in bed with
the government that's the actual
definition of fascism but
we're not ready for that conversation we
want to be polarized so i think we're
right i want to pull up this uh story i
just grabbed from the examiner to answer
some questions for all of you democrats
the party of the wealthy irs data shows
democrats represented 65 percent of
taxpayers with a household income of 500
000 or more in 2020 74 of taxpayers in
republican districts have a household
income of less than one hundred thousand
i think i know why because according to
the data being a democrat is a great way
to save on charity oh yeah i think that
they donate less than
than republicans do they might
oh it might also be not accounting for
the extremes like the top one percent
probably are democrats and that's that's
absolutely yeah and they're like 80
worth 80 billion so that's skewing these
numbers hard like your average if they
remove the top 10 percent in the bottom
10 percent of wealth what's the democrat
and republican but i think
the interesting thing is
that was probably more true 20 years ago
when the republicans were led by
industrialists but republicans have
overwhelmingly been rural and rural
people tend to have lower incomes than
city people so that's just me making
assumptions maybe i'm wrong but i'd
imagine people who live in rural west
virginia are likely going to make much
less money than someone who lives in new
york city on average
someone in new york city is going to be
a democrat someone in rural west
virginia is going to be a republican and
then that there's a gradient effect
where you get closer to the cities you
become more and more democrat but you
also make more and more money the
interesting thing is people used to say
the republicans you you become
republican when you get rich but now
something's changed where i was thinking
you get more conservative when you're
rich but donald trump's not conservative
he's a very liberal guy that became ran
for the republican party so he brought a
bunch of really liberal people away tax
cuts yeah huge tax classically liberal
people well also you made a point which
sort of touched on this earlier but
generally you have to be pretty removed
from reality to support a lot of these
progressive left-wing ideas especially
when you're talking about the social
theories not necessarily all the
economic policies
and when you get into this stuff about
you know being gender fluid for example
this is you know an upper middle class
phenomena i mean at least all of the
people who popularize the ideas these
are not things that the working class is
is all that concerned with the idea of
like being a man who was born in a
woman's body a lot of their arguments
are like that like they're
the the the actual percentage of people
who suffer
from
gender dysphoria as a psychological
condition is very very small so
same thing with the the abortion uh
uh debate that they were having they
were like
oh what about if a woman gets raped or
or whatever incest that literally
accounts for a small the smallest
percentage and you're making a whole
argument over that little thing and it's
just like you just say okay
okay okay so we've okay when they say we
need an exemption for rape or the health
of the mother i'm like all right i agree
let's pull up the data okay two percent
of abortions we'll keep those two
percent we'll ban the other 98. there
you go and they're like wait what no no
no well what do you mean no i agreed
with you so that's the issue you agree
with them they know they're talking
about it's just tribal nonsense yeah
it's kind of like feeding trolls on
social media when someone's response to
you really negatively and if you respond
to that then more people are like oh
that's what gets attention i'll do what
gets attention
and if people are screaming with blue
hair about their gender being wrong and
then all of a sudden they start to get
attention and it's like look at these
crazy people screaming with blue hair
like that's what gets attention okay
i'll do it too so like that's why i
don't want to make a big deal i try not
to make too big a deal out of it and get
angry about it because it just feeds the
fire we maybe need to look into like how
the the millennial as a generation how
they're
like you mentioned they're weak-minded
but also like i feel like a lot of
people are being put on anti-depressants
they're being put on medication they're
being uh sort of like wrapped into this
bubble of
this is where you're safe this is where
you should be and this is and and sort
of like none of that actually has
meaning to you like they're they're told
not to that having a family that
you know being a housewife being
traditional etc that's all but but those
are some of the things that bring the
most joy to people because they're able
to so so it's like you're taking away
the identities of people so that there's
something that can be easily manipulated
didn't someone say someone brought this
up before that there's not enough
there's there's not enough souls for for
as many people as there are alive today
or something like that yeah who was
talking about this that was awesome you
remember that shamus uh i don't remember
i i disagree but i can't remember you
were having a conversation where you
guys and that's sort of how you were
like explaining well someone someone
said that somebody wrote
some like religious figures interesting
wrote that there weren't enough souls
for as many
because we were talking about solipsism
and non-player npcs and all that stuff
and i think it really just feels like
when
when you as we were mentioning earlier
this eclectic group of people of varying
different political ideologies who are
discussing the facts
it seems like that's the case because
there is an entity there that is
actually engaging with you but if you're
talking to an ai
you know they would just say whatever
they were programmed to say as if
there's no one really there that's the
npc meme i i think it's less about not
having a soul but more about
pharmaceutical drugs you brought it up
man and this is like a piece of the
puzzle that's kind of a question mark
because the companies are great the
pharmaceutical companies are keeping
these numbers quiet like pfizer didn't
even want to dump their data for 75
years and how many people that are
having problems wondering about their
gender are on some sort of
pharmaceutical
those things can drive people insane and
if you're under 25 years old your brain
isn't fully developed and you go on a
well they're like oh it's just it's just
adderall adderall is methamphetamine
yeah it's like i think it's four
different amphetamine salts it's
incredible yeah one might be a meth i'm
not sure yeah there's a meth as far as i
know adderall has some sort of it's like
it's amphetamines yeah yeah it's like um
i
feel like
there's uh us a level of
the being that struggles there and not a
lot of people want to understand what is
actually being struggled with so these
people just lash out but like
um for example with my experiences after
my mother was
you know politically persecuted she was
an attorney for the conservative party
at the time they lost the election to
the liberals etc blah blah blah
we went into a period of homelessness we
went into a period of living through
very extreme conditions in the most
violent and poor part of brazil
so i grew up to be this extreme
um
this is extremely sort of like i as as i
was a kid i was sort of soft and and
kind and nice but as i grew up in this
reality it changed me so i went to a
doctor and instead of seeing that as you
know this is who she is this is what
life made of her this is you know
her personality should just assume that
i was sort of depressed and anxious and
and started prescribing me a whole bunch
of medicine
so
of course i'm like i'm gonna take this
because why not right it's part of my
part part of my personality i'm like
self-destructive let's go let's do this
um why not and so then i discovered that
it has a huge half-life and that you
can't just get out of it because if you
get out of it you have all sorts of
so
the east
how easy it was for her to instead of
trying to understand who i am
or how i feel or why i am the way that i
am she just prescribed me a whole bunch
of stuff and said let's try it out and i
find myself like taking five pills a day
like i'm an old lady like with all the
different pills like
what's
what is this what's the purpose of this
adderall is a trade name a combination
of four salts of amphetamine
okay so i'm not sure if there's a meth
in there i i seem to have remembered
seeing one at some point
there's there's there's different types
of dextroumphetamine
and uh
levoamphetamine
and
enantiomers so i will eat that and
humors maybe i misspoke when i said
there's a meth that's methamphetamine
yeah me too it's amphetamines i thought
that was methamphetamine there's math
and there's amphetamine there's two
different types of of adhd it's
dextroumphetamine
they have
the ritalin and concerta and i know that
because i was prescribed all that
it has the meth part of it and then the
adderall has the which is to me is very
scary i i was prescribed and i saw
the bottle and it said amphetamine salts
and i'm like what is this like this
doesn't look right
and imagine like how many
kids are just
taking all this like to me it doesn't
make any sense i think it was
out of 46 000 people that the pfizer
study looked into 42 000 had some sort
of adverse reaction so that's 91.3 that
was a voluntary reporting thing so we we
did we we did a big discussion about
that because even someone who worked for
tim cast published the fake data i got
really angry about that on
methamphetamines no no on the on the
pfizer data that got released basically
what happens is a bunch of people who
started sharing fake news claiming it
was coming from the pfizer data and so
then somehow someone at tim cast saw it
put on the site
then i you know was like put the sources
in it but the sources weren't put in it
i got really really angry we took it
down issued a correction all that stuff
and basically what happened is pfizer
offered up a voluntary reporting period
where anyone
could uh
report if they had an adverse event and
then of adverse events that were
voluntarily reported so the data does
nothing for anybody it proves nothing it
explains nothing it's like i i yelled
out into the wind you know have you ever
got stung by a bee and a thousand people
said yes and i'm like that doesn't so
out of what group like where
says meaningless data but a lot of
people are sharing these memes claiming
it's true and i'm just like it's so
frustrating man yeah i wouldn't
there's there's so much data there that
we need people to actually start going
through and reading the problem is the
people who want to do it don't know how
to interpret the data
so then they screen grab these charts
and they're like look at this and then
you go and read the page before it and
it's like the following data is is is
an example of what a trial might look
like and it's like not even real like in
in the 80 000 pages if data has been
omitted how would anyone even know
because the data is not there to begin
with or if a number was different how
would anyone even know but do we have
people that are actually willing because
for you to do that i feel like you have
to have sort of like it has to be your
job for you to sit down and go through
80 000 pages you have to get paid for it
and so there has to be someone willing
to pay you to do that job now and you
have to be
uh you have to understand the basis for
clinical trials and what these words
mean otherwise people are just being
like
one thing that happened there's a meme
going around
where they're saying the efficacy of the
vaccine was really low and i'm like
that's just bad math because if you
actually just look at the math from the
pfizer data the efficacy was 98 or
something like that but there's another
one where their like mortality was was
three percent and that's one that
befuddled one of our reporters i got mad
about and that was
of voluntary adverse event reports that
went to pfizer within a two-month period
three percent of the reports they
received were for fatalities that may
have been related to the vaccine however
that in the clinical trial it was 0.01
so the actual clinical trial was
microscopic
and then when it was like 6 out of 46
000 people or something like that
suffered some kind of uh event a fatal
event that may have been related we
aren't sure and so it's like even even
that it's like you cannot trust them by
all means but there's nothing definitive
in that data to say someone died because
of it and then people took the voluntary
reporting system
i'll put it this way
if somebody got vaccinated
and then
you know a week later they died the
family of course
is likely to report that
but why did they die we don't know
and so with voluntary reporting data we
have no control group we don't know how
large the sample size is we don't know
what these people died of none of that
the same thing is true for the various
stuff that's getting reported i'm like
it should definitely be investigated i
think you know any anomalous number
needs to be
heavily investigated we don't have that
right now and so you basically have one
side which is the establishment
dismissing all of it outright which is
psychotic
then you have a middle ground of people
being like can we please just like get
someone to look into why all these
reports came out and then you have
another side that's claiming it's the
apocalypse yeah but it's like that's i
think that that's the biggest thing for
why it shouldn't have been mandated at
the the executive level because we don't
have the information right now we don't
have the even even study groups and and
different types of studies can have some
level of bias so it's sort of like it
takes different studies it takes
different uh
conditions it takes different
environments it takes like how how are
we gonna know the the long-term effects
of this if the time hasn't passed so we
don't have that information so that's
why sort of like
everybody sort of
guessing at this point what actually is
going to happen based on this study or
that study but but the reality is
it shouldn't have been mandated at the
first in the first place because we just
don't know
i don't think any medications should be
mandated that there's there's
some arguments about i mean there's like
a libertarian argument a private
business can do what they want i think
scale is the issue you can't
some people if some people can't get a
medication it can't be mandated i just
think for the most part mandates are
just just wrong maybe you're talking
vaccines for a country where there's
well-documented evidence of it
functioning to prevent people from
getting malaria or dengue fever or
something then yeah but i'm open to that
conversation but if you can inoculate
yourself why should someone else be
forced to
it's tough because i don't hurt immunity
right there that's the argument
i don't know man i think you're right on
the money dude top-down medicine doesn't
seem to work the evidence shows that you
have people with massive amounts of
adverse reactions which is why they're
working on 3d printing medicine that can
they can be tailored for your body you
know your own chemistry and then you can
produce your own version of it
ew
like like it's it's to me it
yeah but it sort of like makes it a more
natural thing to be taking something
versus
what happened to going outside in the
sun and and getting some you know
exposure and getting some exercise and
moving like i had this i've i sit a lot
because i'm always writing and what not
and then the doctor is like oh you're 28
so you probably have early onset or
trident let me give you all these
medicines like what
um
goodbye i do not have arthritis
um
it's sort of like i read it on the
internet of course webmd uh that i was
either pregnant or die
no not really but
like uh a veteran webmd that it's a
common thing for people who will do a
lot of best job like like writing to get
uh
one side of their hip um
to have a little bit of a a pain on it
because it's sort of like an
inflammation right like you'd have it if
you
whatever so it's not arthritis and um
i'm not taking out the medicine that he
prescribed me i think i think the answer
is obviously just to only eat lamb there
you go eat nothing apparently michaela
peterson might agree with you i think
hypochondria is a massive problem with
people and i think munchaus and people
uh
munchas and sinja by proxy is a big
problem where they're like ah my arm
hurts let me look online what is wrong
with me oh and then they look at five
things like oh that's one i'm gonna
start thinking and then they think about
it think about it think about it they go
like do i have this thing and they're
like dude your arm hurt massage your arm
cut back on the sugar what no i'm not
giving medical advice here but take care
of yourself if something hurts fix it do
something change your posture so your
back doesn't hurt you'd have to go to
get a prescription for it off the bat
come on no matter what you look up on
webmd it says you have cancer that's
it's funny it's like you know my wrist
has been hurting and it's like things
that may be happening tendinitis cancer
and i'm like i don't think it's cancer
but okay
i guess cancer can cause everything okay
i like that we're talking about
pharmaceutical pharmaceutical industry
because this is a this is part of this
whole gender experience that i think
people are going through that they are
medicating children from maybe i don't
know how old three years old six years
old what is the earliest you can give a
kid a psychoactive pharmaceutical i
think they're uh like
seven or seven between seven and nine
years old i think they're doing it maybe
maybe what we need
is pharmacies should just be like
libraries like public libraries where
anyone of any age can walk in and just
take any drug off the shelf and walk out
with it i mean as long as you bring it
back
well it's a library tim it's going to be
overdue yeah exactly no you have to
bring them just take it to look at it
public then you bring it back later no
checks
they're they're one of the things one of
the arguments that they're saying
about uh
transgender kids is that if you put them
on puberty blockers it's not going to do
anything to harm them but like
yes it is like oh we're doing we're not
transitioning the kid we're just putting
them on puberty blockers then they say
define harm that's right their bone
density doesn't change and it's like but
through puberty your bone density
strengthens but nothing changes it's
supposed to change it's a good thing for
it to change and so you just deprived
them of like going through an extremely
instrumental and important bodily
process the opportunity cost if you're
not able to get better than you are
actually getting worse in the grand
scheme let's go to super chats
if you haven't already would you kindly
hit that like button
i'll now wait
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel and would you kindly go to
timcast.com and become a member i think
this is going to work
i think everybody who understands what
the reference is it will work do you
guys know the reference no no
okay that's all that matters oh he ain't
giving it away no now you know now
so uh
spoiler alert how's that 23 how old was
that game 20 years i don't know how many
years here and it's one of the best of
all time it's so good bioshock the
original one so
basically whenever the guy it's ruining
for the game for anybody who might play
because you could it's a great game um
whenever the guy says would you kindly
it's compelling this the guy to do
whatever he says does he have nanobots
in his body that responds
so he'd be like would you kindly lift
that lever and then like you have to do
it
everyone's like bioshock yes uh
subscribe to the channel share the show
with your friends smash that like button
would you kindly and we'll read some
more
we'll read some super chats
all right steve
van volkenberg says pro abortion ad was
the first thing that came on when i
clicked your stream the good news is
that means they're giving me their money
yeah supporting me having a conversation
around it so there you go i loved it
when michael bloomberg dumped 500
million i think it was and everyone's
like i get nothing but bloomberg ads on
your channel i'm like well he's lying in
my box of the gold i guess funding this
operation
i know you were funded by big bloomberg
there you go big bloomberg earl graham
says love the show tim how much are you
willing to bet twitter suddenly gets hit
with a cyber attack and loses all of its
info elon is looking into
i would not be surprised yeah i've been
waiting for that to happen actually i'm
surprised it hasn't yet twitter just
goes down for a week oh no oh geez can't
buy it now
i wonder if last night youtube going out
was a cyber attack i keep thinking about
cyber attacks in this era
can you uh
can you can you read this one i can't
read this this is in portuguese oh uh
okay uh i can't read that because i am
blind oh okay probably and and
and you shouldn't if you're saying
ella are they saying anything offensive
[Music]
that's it
can i see that like i can scoot over oh
i mean you can just get up and walk over
and look at it
so someone someone sent portuguese
is it not portuguese
it is right um yeah it's portuguese but
i don't know what sopa jima kako is oh
well then i guess we'll
we tried
oh okay i think that's just offensive
i was hoping it was going to be some
kind of offensive thing that's like we
got to read that no we just don't know
raymond g stanley jr says ian did you
use jeremy's razor oh i did not use
jeremy's razors uh at from i hate
harry's.com to shave my face no i didn't
it was an electric i haven't used a
straight edge razor in like 20 years
missed opportunity maybe once i'm very
curious what that soup was
she was like you got to get him you got
to get her to say something about soup
i don't know if it because we have c's
they have the little you know yeah
dingley i don't know you gotta explain
you gotta get another super chat going
are you a big fan of soup
yeah actually i love some oh yeah there
you go that's it
twx rated says netflix totally went 360.
shareholders are not happy about losing
profit due to the garbage woke ideology
all netflix should care about is
treating employees with respect making
good content and turning a profit for
investors but going a 360 means they
went back to where they started mm-hmm
180 might have been the number 180 yeah
unless you're on a half pipe because
then you do land fakie if you go up and
do a 360. so that's what he meant
certainly that's right he's speaking
about vert not street
stronger than stones i don't really want
to defend big mouth but isn't it
protected under the first amendment as
gross as it is at least it's adult
actors acting and not children like
cuties oh you know for sure that's why
i'm like it's disgusting and i don't
like it
but i never like
rallied and made videos where i was like
ah when cuties happened i then was like
and also look what they're doing with
big mouth i think you got a bunch of
diddlers working at netflix i don't use
the first amendment argument for stuff
like that but i think that innuendo
is is an important
tool so you got to be you got to speak
up if you see people using it society
needs to pull up like like police itself
it's not the job of the government to do
that like society needs to come up and
say sorry for interrupting you but like
i feel like a lot of these things were
outsourcing to the government when we
could just have society police itself
and like when you do something like that
you're gonna be ostracized you're gonna
be there's gonna be social consequences
for doing that even if it is protected
under the first amendment it's terrible
it's immoral so
it's it's like like if you were talking
about like the social
that consequ um
international or whatever like you can't
just say that because you know you're
gonna lose your job you're gonna so
there are no social consequences for a
lot of the stuff that the left puts
forth so so this is a good one king of
diamonds says a person once called me a
philippines and i cringed so hard and
found it insulting
phillip
what
can we not
wow i agree x is the coolest letter but
come on come on man
pedro says tim ask julia bolsonaro 2022
or not yes oh there you go simple answer
what do you what do you think people in
brazil uh do you think it's like trump
like a lot of people really do like him
the media the media
by the way it's like the media is in
brazil's like the media lying about him
and and all that stuff yeah yeah yeah
it's it's very similar very similar oh
yeah brazilian trump man i thought he
was so evil when i first heard of him
because of the media right bolsonaro
someone plunged a machete like right
like into his
like gut that was crazy
yeah crazy man
brazil is massive by the way
massive mostly rain forest
no actually the area that i'm from is
sort of like a desert type of it's by
the equator so
if you go to the left everybody asks me
like oh you're from brazil so you're
from rio no uh sao paulo no amazonia no
i'm like literally as far away removed
from those places as can be
um
but yeah no the
there's the the the most of the country
is sort of like tropical forest but not
really like rain floors like how many
how many people live in sao paulo
a bunch a bunch quite a few is it i
think south paw is like one of the
biggest cities in the world it's like
insanely massive millions yeah whoa but
more more than just you want to look it
up because i'm pretty sure it's like
ridiculously large mm-hmm well
it's real refined coconuts for a dollar
12th most populous on earth okay 12th
wow most populous in brazil
yeah i was hanging out in rio it was
great you sit there and then they come
with a coconut and they break it open
for yeah you've been oh yeah yeah
several times that's right i had to get
my brazilian visa
i was from peru you should go you should
go to my area next time it's uh the
northeast my my visa is still good for a
couple years there you go what's what's
it called etrusco is that where they
come with the meat and they slice it
onto your plate strahuska yeah that was
so cool looks like there's 12.4 million
and then in the macro metropolis there's
33.6 million i thought it was 33.
massive
that's crazy i think new york is like in
the macro it's like 12 or something oh
there's 18 might something is it i think
so but i have to re look it up again jn
says in the book of revelation
the antichrist will be someone who will
change the established time and seasons
the spirit of antichrist is active right
now acting against everything that is
god's hint the spirit will manifest into
a real person god bless y'all that true
shames i don't know i need to double
check that you don't know i
know believe i don't have the entire
bible memorized it's very embarrassing
please don't don't but but just don't
tell anyone haven't you ever seen the
answer the book of eli
yes yes you should be able to recite
from memory every passage that book is
that movie was amazing it was genuinely
a good film new york is 20 million in
the macro metro wow 18.8 in the wow the
main city was that before the covet and
everybody started working for malmo i
think that there's less people i don't
know what year this is i would imagine
it's the most recent census data
i don't know
cody jones says
the mass brainwashing was to be achieved
in two ways the transformation of the
school curriculum and the creation of
bodies one gender
i think it's like um
it's it's it's infantilization right
they don't want people to mature into
adulthood and so we're seeing that
culturally and we're literally seeing it
with puberty blockers and yes
psychedelic psychoactive pharmaceuticals
because if you can't cry and be upset
and wonder what's wrong with you as a
kid you're never going to become an
adult
you've got to suffer man it's part of
growing up i feel like they try to
isolate you so like
there's a thousand different categories
that you fit into and you can never
relate to your neighbor anymore because
you're like oh you i'm a woman okay so
now i'm isolated from 50 of the
population i have to celebrate the fact
that i'm a woman i have to do this i
have to do that okay now i am a woman of
color i am a woman more visitor and so
they put you in a box that by the time
they're done
it's only you in that box you don't you
don't relate to your neighbor there's no
like like there's no sense of a
community anymore you're just stuck in
this one box where everybody's sort of
like out to get you everybody's sort of
conflicting against your interests and
to me it's just like a way of
making people not only weaker in the
mind but also
uh
preying on these people you know be cool
would be cooler though if what was
really happening is that you guys ever
see that tom cruise movie oblivion
uh part of it yeah part of it where it's
basically spoiler alert it's an old
movie
there's like a giant tetrahedron in
outer space and
ted tom cruise thinks that he's like
helping migrate off the earth but what
really happened is that aliens destroyed
the planet and then cloned a whole bunch
of astronauts to use as foot soldiers on
the ground to like
steal all the water and use it for
fusion energy whoa that's awesome yeah
cool movie like the the
uh storm troopers that's sort of like
i feel like clowns yeah it'd be cool if
they like aliens had invaded oh you guys
ever watched target sg-1
nope no i've seen a couple episodes but
i've never really there's this deep on
the scene there's this planet
that secretly gets taken over by the bad
guys and they don't know but they were
like technologically advanced and so the
bad guys are basically running the
planet i don't know that's just an idea
like you know we're being we're being
conquered and destroyed by aliens
how could that be internet coming from
above they're coming from within that's
right thanks that's good what if that
really what if yeah you know it'd be
really funny so like we have the alex
jones was right jar but what if like the
final moments you know the great the
climax of the story of whatever hap
happens is like a portal opens up and
the international beings come out and
the earth has been like prepared for
them and then all of a sudden everyone
was like they they dropped to their
knees and they're like alex jones was
right like everyone's screaming and
at the clouds part and you see alex's
face in the sky and no no no no no hold
on i got better with us the whole time
200 years in the future
it's like
humanity has defeated the demons and the
interdimensional beings and there's like
alex jones high and it's like you know
there's a 50 bill with alex on it yeah
and they're like he's like a prophet
he's like the founding father who who
knew the interdimensional beings are
coming to turn people into cow hybrids
with the 5g or whatever and then
adobe the alex jones day
alex jones day yes it's like you know
where are you from oh i'm from um
chicago alex jones
yeah alex
rename the state to alex jones oh gotcha
yeah yeah
all right let's read some more super
chats
joseph says i'm thinking about your
perspective when you say walking into
the woods is freedom also when you say
people don't understand the cycle of
life growing fruit for a start that
happened to you
when we were little
when i was in school they made us grow
um
beans did you guys ever do that
everybody got potting soil and then you
have the seeds and everybody had to
water their plant and it would grow and
then we were like oh and then we got to
eat it yeah i was like look and then we
went home and we cooked and we ate it
was fun
my growing stuff too in the early days
and then we had you know i think you
know we had a fruit tree in the backyard
we had a cherry tree or something but
i'm like somewhat allergic to cherries
so i couldn't yeah it might have been if
you're eating raw they have like tannins
i think on the skin yeah i can't they
can't do it but if i cook them i can
yeah there you go yeah but just keep
saying like uh prepare for the end of
the world by planting your own stuff
i tried to plant some stuff last winter
and then up i was too far i tried to
plant some stuff last winter you can
move the microphone and then
yeah
and then uh turns out i i try to eat it
it turns out it was a terrible terrible
weed
the stuff that i planted never actually
took
and um yeah
just just look up uh before you pick
something from the ground i couldn't i
couldn't imagine eating wheat wheat yeah
it's dry like when when when i look at
things that are growing and we grew you
know pumpkins and zucchinis and carrots
and tomatoes i'm like look at this
amazing bounty and then i see fields of
wheat and i'm like who thought one day
like i'm gonna eat that i guess you're
hungry you're gonna eat it
yeah yeah it's weird they used to do
barley i think they still do what do you
mean yeah i actually just ordered some
barley uh extract some barley powder
that i'm putting there's cereal made of
it okay but the romans i meant the
romans used all right z kraken says last
night members only was interesting
sheamus i'm glad you kept your composure
yet firm have you read chariots of the
gods ian have you read that book as well
i have not have you read that i've heard
of it it's what ancient aliens is based
on oh yesterday was funny because uh
will so here's what happens will
chamberlain was the guest for the show
well got wrecked in the after show
yeah he didn't really represent himself
very well we label the members only
shows based on the guest from that night
so people can correlate yeah but will
had to leave because he's with his
family and so i was like well what do i
call this members video to correlate
with the episode i guess we'll call it
the will chamberlain okay and so i just
took a screenshot of an empty chair and
put will is invisible and doesn't talk
the entire time so like to make a joke
about it someone was like you missed
opportunity put fishing line on the mic
and then pull it really hard when you
got up and smacked it
that's a good idea
yeah if we had fishing line i suppose
sean st george says when i was in school
and a manager i was told that if someone
calls asking for recommendations on
former employees to confirm they did
work there and that was it saying more
could open the company up to liability
that is true
you can't say bad things
you say employer can't say bad things if
you're trying to get a recommendation
some advice oh okay don't ask them
anything personal say
did ian crossland work for this company
yes would you hire him again
no thank you very much have a nice day
there you go
because then they're not saying anything
bad about you it's just their you know
would they hire you or not yeah you can
you can get in big trouble if you defame
people like that i guess but i would not
that's what you say
the connolly says they should change the
law and let women get their tubes tied
at any age so they won't be worried
about having kids if you want to stop a
pregnancy you shouldn't be a mom
i mean i think there's an issue of
if one group of people is continually
sterilizing
or aborting their children
and trying not to have kids and another
side is like don't abort your children
and sterilize them and let's have a
bunch of kids seems like the future is
going to be a bunch of religious
conservatives yeah and i will also say
when i was 21 i went to the doctor and i
was like will you please tie my tubes i
don't want to have children this world
seems terrible and i helped raise my
four younger children and she said no
you're too young and my goodness am i
glad she said no that was her opinion or
was that legal um that was her opinion a
lot of doctors will tell you the same
thing and it turns out they're right is
it reversible
uh tying your tubes i don't believe is
not like a vasectomy okay yeah aurelio
and by the way keeping a vasectomy is
not always reversible
either yeah aurelio says tim you need to
make an ultra maga t-shirt with a
transformer autobot that looks like
donald trump no no magatron yeah
yeah
i like it someone a bunch of people
already posted that meme so you know
make magatron shirts ultra maga
da
sideways 2013 says how do you feel about
the vein on snickers bars
i have no idea what that is like on the
top of the bar that little like thing
that runs along it that looks like i saw
some meme joke or something where they
were like bring it back they got rid of
it they made it smooth freaked out
was that was that true or something or
what i think
i mean i assume sheamus doesn't know
because he was following the eminem
thing
we did a cartoon about the m m thing
yeah you guys should definitely check
that out carlson bernie sanders she's my
wife oh daddy changed that eminem i'm so
angry what i liked about this
on the milky way was that it it you knew
it was a milky way if you looked at it
from above that was i thought so kind of
branded the bar by doing that little
thing butterfingers didn't have
to stay away from it
aren't candy bars psychotic
i mean it's basically like a huge drug
it's just a it's a big part it's just
insane it's like sugar barely occurs in
nature we've hyper concentrated it made
several different forms
smeared it with chocolate and it's this
massive wad of sugar sugar and sugar we
it's just like it's like 11 days small
minds are afraid of progress that's
right
i just think like
we we have like a box of chocolates
downstairs or something and you open it
there's like one little chocolate i'm
like that's cool and you can eat it
that's good or you'll get like a
chocolate bar and you'll break off a
tiny piece but then there's like a
snickers and a milky way which is just
are you seriously gonna eat that maybe
like take a
cut of it like fun size it's funny the
amount of sugar chocolate caramel and
other whatever is in candy bars if you
actually cut it up it would be like a
full box of chocolates
imagine going to the store and buying a
box of chocolates instead of just eating
it all and i don't have to imagine
because i've done it in the past i ate a
bag of kitkats and then a bag of
chocolate eggs all in one night and i
broke out on this open rash like over my
pancreas or something it was like yo
take your life into your own hands man
halloween's funny yeah they just give
kids poison i mean i'm gonna call it
poison tongue-in-cheek but they i think
they should be regulating it like they
do the tobacco industry and not be
selling it to kids with cartoons and
stuff
yeah like on the cigarettes how they
used to have pictures of people who are
all disfigured they just have to have
like pictures of really really fat kids
on the candy so
rotting teeth and oh my goodness then
the dental industry comes in and makes a
fortune on it
all right it isn't saying how much sugar
and also how much sugar is in the
general food like the fact that diabetes
has become so common yeah that's
something that i noticed when i moved
here to the u.s it's like everything
there's sugar even in the meat and
barbecue sauce like people are pretty
barbecue sauce and i'm like this is just
sugar meat like that's what it means so
you ever go to panda express
no it's amazing they take wads of
chicken
roll it in bread
fry it in oil smear sugar syrup all over
it hey and then they give you a bowl of
rice don't knock pan express it's like i
think it actually is like what two
thousand calories and like ian's looking
at me like oh it's grimace that was my
grandmother oh good though it's really
nice oh the good is the strange word
see the problem is that americans think
that everything needs to be a treat
everything needs to be a dessert
everything does not need to be a treat
no low carbs waste you know what i've
been eating lately good point i take an
egg
i take some walnut flour and some almond
flour
i stir it up microwave it and it turns
into a biscuit put some egg cheese and
bacon on it boom it's done good that's a
mayonnaise lydia i think that's a really
good point we expect every single meal
we eat to be
very
enjoyable and pleasing i mean
historically people were eating the
foods that they could get
it's it's such a luxury to enjoy
something you actually enjoy or to eat
something you actually enjoy the taste
of every single meal we take it for
granted when i when i lived in l.a and i
was dirt poor
i would go to this local uh mexican
market
and i'd have like a dollar fifty and i
could get a pack of tortillas for like
80 cents cool then i could get like six
tomatoes for like 30 cents
and then i would take the tortillas put
them on the stove and crisp them and put
tomatoes on it and it was so delicious
yeah tomatoes it was just so corn
tortillas and then every so often i'd
take a dollar and i'd buy something from
hardy's or carl's jr which everyone's in
los angeles and that was uh
my my point is
simple things taste so good
when you're hungry and you need food and
for americans our portions are so big
that it's like things stopped tasting
good
and i was talking about you know we had
someone here i think mary she made
cookies or something and then i was like
make keto ones with like no sugar and
like almond flour whatever she's like
why and i'm like when you when you stop
eating sugar everything starts tasting
better it's true because like your your
senses get dulled to it yeah it takes
about 10 days and then man a carrot
starts to you know when a carrot is
sweet that you've got the right sugar
balance in your body for the most part
or you don't have too much in your body
right here's how you make a milkshake
you take cold brew
some heavy cream and ice and you blend
it boom it tastes like a chocolate
milkshake it's so good yeah sugar no
sugar cold brew coffee with some peanut
butter powder and honey and it was like
whoa
even that too i'm like i don't i cut out
most sugars but i'll do a little bit of
honey every so often and it doesn't mess
me up
the the bread really it was like if i
eat any kind of bread it's like someone
punched me in the face
can i can i come clean here on the show
is this life can i come clean yeah yeah
yeah you eat bread
i actually don't know
what's in a snickers bar or a milky way
keep it that way same thing one's got
peanuts one doesn't there you go okay
caramel never had that nougat it's
called you've never had either because
that's not like an embarrassing thing
that's actually ideal yeah no keep it
that way yeah
like like a like a wafer and then it's
no there's no way for it what's that
that
that's a nougat like the cracker thing
that's in there cracker yeah there's
like a layer of there's no yeah you're
talking about twix kitkat i thought
there was a milky way is nougat and
caramel chocolate peanuts snickers has
peanuts
yeah that's right
i always liked whatchamacallits you ever
had one of those yeah
zero bars those are good
fifth avenue oh candy bars it's crazy
that millennials have basically cut off
the bad food like soda sales are in the
gutter because millennials don't want to
drink soda
i think soda is disgusting
like legit if someone was like would you
like to drink you know a pepsi i'd be
like that's disgusting it tastes like
drinking syrup
50 grams pepsi
you know what i do
a shot of lemon juice and club soda
that's just like lemon soda yeah i feel
like the the the balance between pepsi
and and coca-cola is just that coca-cola
uses a lot more acid or something to
cut down on the on the the sweetness the
sweetness because pepsi tastes sweeter
but like
coke doesn't but like if you let it sit
a little bit and all the the fizzly
stuff goes away then it tastes just as
as sweet um but um here goes if i
wha not if
when i make it to a hundred thousand
followers i will
eat a snickers bar don't ruin your life
don't do it your kimchi you don't need
to that's what you want next
my 600 pound life snickers oh that is a
thing deep fried and what there is
nothing that this country is too ashamed
to deep fry
dude you can go to a carnival and they
will take a milky way oreos batter it
and deep fry it for you it is so good it
is using the word good again i don't
know it is so delicious
oh the soda's disgusting no no no no no
no no no no hold on yes
listen
sheamus you'd agree a deep-fried milky
way is sin incarnate
i mean look i wouldn't go that far
probably not good for you i mean like
i'm not gonna recommend people eat it
what about selling stuff that's not good
for kids to kids is that sin no that's a
good question i mean if
that's we'd have to look at the specific
thing we'd have to think about like how
seriously bad it is because like is one
candy bar every once in a while could it
destroy somebody no
i think i think there is an argument to
be made like i i don't have like a
specific prescription here my point was
just that the concept of a candy bar to
me is kind of crazy because they're
they're huge
like a lindor truffle what do rich
people eat they're like give me a small
truffle it's like this tiny little ball
of chocolate you get a box of fancy
chocolates
i'm telling you like a milky way would
be like eating a whole box of chocolates
i think about that beer too one beer is
too much alcohol
you need like half a third of that will
get you to the right spot if you drink
the alcohol that is lightweight disagree
seriously i mean if you don't have
anything
the irish guy disagrees yeah like that
that's the minimum
all right let me let me read some more
subjects we got tyler who said i'm a
chemist adderall is one methyl group
different than meth anyone takes
adderall knows why people are addicted
to meth similar effects from each that's
what i've heard good to know now we're
talking we need more more doctors on the
show yeah absolutely talk chemicals
alicia i'm not good enough for you yeah
elisha
says or alexa adderall is one molecule
of off of meth is what i've heard also i
dated a girl on zoloft and she
desperately wanted to get off of it
doctors never told her that weaning off
is almost impossible you have to tell
people that you have to wean off
antidepressants and i went off so loft
with no trouble
you lose control of your thoughts you
don't have any control over what you're
thinking and it's terrifying so you need
to know so often antidepressant but like
what does that mean you lose control of
your thoughts you'll start thinking
things that are completely foreign to
you that you've that are completely
inconsistent with what you believe with
who you are as a person scary thoughts
antipsychotics to do that like i have a
friend of mine he said that whenever he
got on antipsychotics
it was like there's a period of time i
guess that
everybody was
it was the big thing i guess to
prescribe that um and so his mom
hypochondriac whatever gave him
uh um got him on antipsychotics and he
said he had some really bad weird
thoughts that he wouldn't normally ever
have or come to have again right once he
got out of the medicine so it's like
it's just
they they sort of like keep all the bad
side effects and possible things out of
the picture and it's just all kumbaya
it's a problem when you have hard bad
thoughts and you go on kalanapan or
wellbutrin i've had horrible experiences
with friends trying to kill themselves
like those don't make you not have the
bad those don't like change it the past
the past is still real and you have to
deal with the past to be in the present
let's read some more we got cowboy bears
alex jones is right but remember that
episode of darkwing duck which he went
to another dimension where he was a
famous figure the author of the dw comic
just had a radio listening to dw
dimension
that's um i think the premise of
bioshock infinite
the dude can open or the the the woman
opens rifts and so the guy can like
reach through other dimensions and times
and steal information so like songs it's
cool it's cool there's like
a barbershop quartet singing beach boys
because he stole the song from another
dimension and brought it and then sold
it or whatever
yeah i mean it works the beach boy is
very much like a high-pitched barbershop
quartet it it it's very great
jenny's getting inky with it says would
you consider having kathy barnett on re
how gop is treating her ask poso about
her sheamus a doctor jekyll mr hydevid
showing left as reuben and mao would be
hilarious
oh that would be good maybe we should do
something like that yeah and it's got to
be like it has to be that
when other leftists start getting close
he doesn't understand like something's
happening to me i don't understand
no but it's true like you are left-wing
in proportion of how close other
left-wingers are to you in most cases no
no no no no hold on sorry i'm sorry it's
like 10 dave rubins standing in an open
field and as they come closer i agree
and then i disagree i disagree i
disagree
as they get closer they all start
disagreeing
yeah turning into mao turns into like
left wing and fighting they're shoving i
disagree actually this would be really
good it's a scientist explaining a a a
physics a physicist explaining a natural
phenomenon is like when the the reuben
molecule is moved far away and then once
they start moving closer together they
start shifting into what's called a mao
particle there are no left-wing
individuals only left-wing groups
mao particle the mao particle all right
we'll grab something but i also want to
mention this like when i've had
conversations with anyone here off air
like when we talk about fair it's not
like ian doesn't like graphene when he's
not on camera you know everyone here is
pretty clear about their perspective
yeah and so
maybe it's the case with like
you know i can't speak to left-wing
influencers or all of them at the very
least some of them seem to be
hypocritical but
i just find with so many people who like
are dying the whole leftist when they're
not with other people they're like less
left-wing i'm glad you're graphing
shamus let me read this one pat says i'm
trying my best to cut out sugars big
energy drinks are still my main weakness
any ideas gang so there are sugar-free
energy drinks yes uh but
they typically have like splenda or
something i'm not a fan what are those
things are they called numa yeah pneuma
pneuma yeah we got these energy drinks
that have that it's like coconut water
so it's like naturally sweet and then
the energy drinks we have are actually
almost like no sugar and i think it's um
allulose seven grams of carbs and they
also have electrolytes yeah it's an
interesting sugar substitute it's a
great it's a type of sugar also in
addition to food one thing i found is if
i eat a lot of sugar and i want it out
of my body i do a plank and i just hold
it for like however many minutes i can
hold the plank and it hurts it's it's
much harder when you have sugar in your
body but you burn off a bunch of sugar
and then the next couple days it's a
little bit easier and then the plank
becomes easier too ladies and gentlemen
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and head over
to timcast.com become a member to
support our work we're expanding
infrastructure we are now as i mentioned
several times on rumble's infrastructure
so support businesses
that are working towards building that
alternative ecosystem that parallel
economy as it were we're gonna have more
announcements coming soon because we're
constantly working on these on these
developments and uh it's going to be a
great weekend you can check out chicken
city at chickencitylive.com or the cass
castle vlog we've got a bunch of really
cool stuff happening this month you're
going to be really surprised the
expansion this is going to be a really
really big year for everything we're
working on bringing on more people doing
more shows it's going to be a whole lot
of fun and let me just say
our strategy in these next few months is
to assert ourself
in the dominant establishment cultural
spaces so things should get interesting
to say the least but it's because of you
we're we're we're going to tell these
people that they're not the elites
anymore that we are coming in and we are
asserting our cultural presence so again
follow the smash like button follow the
show at tim cast irl you can follow me
at tim cast julia do you want to shout
anything out we are the mega kings
um yes yes i do uh so i want to give a
quick shout out to
the marco polo project um they're doing
a very thorough
research on the hunter byzantine laptop
and it has hundreds of pages of very
very good information investigative
reporting information that you like when
you see it in big mainstream outlets
that's where they're getting their
information from uh it's it's a a work a
piece of art from a journalistic
standpoint so i want to give them lots
of props for what they're doing they're
uncovering so much stuff from the the
biden family that's just disgusting and
you know makes them so unfit for the
president to see and and i don't know
because a lot of the times these things
come out and
we just don't give a damn like we move
on like we didn't just see you know
hunter biden's
um body body
yes
but but um awful nevertheless it's a
great effort so i want to give a shout
out also
wherever you are you're going to find me
at rio julia song if you type i really
love song and i'm not there it's not me
if you type and i'm there it may be me
uh hopefully it will be me some
sometimes i don't know
like um
yeah yeah just just use your judgment
i am seamus coghlan i have youtube
channel called freedom tunes you guys
need to go over there and check it out
we released a video yesterday called bro
v wade i think you will all really enjoy
that we're going to be releasing some
awesome stuff next week that i think
you'll like as well go over there hit
the notification bell and i also have an
exciting announcement that i will be
making next week oh well unfortunately
don't spoil it don't spoil it tim i'm
not gonna be here i'm not gonna be here
next week sheamus i'm gonna miss your
surprise oh you better watch the show
i'm gonna watch the show i'm on the road
i'll be traveling across the country
with my beautiful girlfriend she's
moving out here i'm very excited uh i
don't know if that's necessary for the
world to know but now you know she's
awesome and uh to the person that asked
another way to get off sugar we were
talking about allulose is one coconut
water straight coconut water when that
beet starts to become sweet you're
balancing out your ph
great stuff i love you all and i will
see you in a while a week from now
thank you guys for tuning in this
evening this lovely evening with a
lovely lovelia lovely julia song really
appreciate you all tuning in i want to
say too for quitting sugar i thought
that diet soda was a good bridge between
drinking soda and not drinking soda and
then sparkling water is also really good
if you want to stop said all together i
love peanut butter as a snack that is
very low in sugar as well anyway that's
just my two cents it's something i'm
working on too you guys may follow me on
twitter mines.com at sourpatchlits also
at sourpatchlids.me also i i just want
to mention i want to respond to the
chats and if this in the butt uh the
announcement is not that i'm pregnant oh
no
i don't believe them i was going to
bring that up it's either pregnant dead
or cancer
he's like i got a great announcement in
one week i have cancer
that's such a great announcement no no
all right everybody thanks for hanging
out it's been an awesome week it's an
awesome friday go have some fun and uh
check out chickencitylive.com become a
member at timcast.com we've got a bunch
of stuff in the works we're going crazy
this year we are going to be doing
really really crazy stuff you know
we got to get the let's go brandon blimp
out there oh yeah i was thinking like
can we donate that somewhere
man we'll figure that one out thanks for
hanging out everybody and we'll see you
all next time
you